family family family family family
family family family family family
family family family family
we ascended into coldness
jared leto style absolutely i'm gonna be
throwing a white robe only
summit and some uh
island where everything's illegal where
there's no water south here okay
let's go to yourself that'd be a good
place to party and white attire everyone
will be in white tire i'll be wearing
red or something and everyone else will
wear
yeah yeah yeah that's joker brain is fun
that's the cult [ __ ]
[Laughter]
actually speaking of jared leto
i'm happy to say or i don't know if
happy is the right word but
um there was that movie that came out
that everyone was hyped through oh the
house of goo
jared leto was in it yeah and i'm happy
to say
that everybody hated his performance
right am i right that was universal
reaction
so that's good i believe it got panned
by critics i actually i actually enjoyed
his performance
[Laughter]
oh i haven't seen the movie so you're
entitled to that opinion but
i just don't know how he's a serious
actor
after all we've seen from him
he did win an academy award
mm-hmm for the dallas buyers in some
very good movies
yeah well fair
despite him
perhaps
i mean come on anyway welcome to after
dark
it's friday baby
sponsored by raycon and mint mobile
thank you guys so much
i'm so tired i feel like dude did make
dd mega doo doo today were you tread
milling in final fantasy all night dude
okay no
the new final fantasy expansion came out
last night at one
yeah that's a little rough so i was like
okay i'm trying to log in
trying to log in get in
there's like a 3 000 person wait list
but i'm waiting patiently like a good
boy
i get down
to the very
end of the queue ready to log in
here we go
i go to take i'm just i'm sorry this is
crude i'm
taking i'm you know
passing stool
is that
defecation you're defecating what's the
nicest way to say it defecating is
passing stool
i was dropping a stool sample off yeah i
think i might have [ __ ] my pants
i'm not as crude as mike
so i was i was dropping um
let's say i was like a turd you know
flaming turd bag all right i was i was
dropping the bread dough off
i was i was lit i was pinching a loaf i
was uh
putting the bread
loafs out to rise
dropping the kids off at the pool
what
yeah
anyway so what happens was i was on the
toilet
finished ready to you know finish up
the power goes out in the whole [ __ ]
house now we have an electric toilet
it's a big day i cannot flush this
toilet when the power goes out wait even
the flush
i don't know
i don't know if we don't know how to do
it but
you would think there would be a way i
was tinkering i was looking everywhere i
was pushing everything
as far as i can tell there's no way to
flush this [ __ ] toilet when there's
no electricity
and um so i've got a giant [ __ ] in my
toilet that i can't flush and
i can't log into my goddamn game
there's no power all night long
i'm walking around by candlelight like
damn uh
who's the guy in the christmas carol
ebenezer yeah like ebenezer scrooge
ebenezer klein
i was feeling like ebenezer scrooge last
night damn
damn
oh okay av yeah there's a manual flush
button available on the right i pushed
that [ __ ] button bro trust me like a
thousand times yeah there's a little
button on the side it says for flushing
it doesn't work
it does not work
and in fact if you don't trust me i'll
put it on my story today
even though we do have the turd still in
there no
to be honest i forgot to check this
morning i know it could be
but what i just i don't think it is
because
it's downstairs in our kind of like
public bathroom
how are you doing you're at target is
this a paid uh target
integration
i'm
doing some shopping right now it's
friday shopping today is the day to shop
it's every friday oh you shop every
friday look at some trees
yeah
okay that [ __ ] those shelves look
stacked what are you what are you
looking at there
i'm trying to look at christmas trees
and stuff all right hell yeah yeah
christmas um lights
it looks good on the tree
um is can you ask that employee behind
you if it's okay your mask is down for
the call
it is okay my master's down for the call
all right oh he's good oh approved
interesting
awesome thank you thanks to that store
employee what a guy what a guy how you
been how was your um thanksgiving it's
great i had a good turkey
makes me sleepy
oh yeah
you eat your fair share of good food
oh yeah oh definitely
deserve that turkey all year baby
[ __ ] hell yeah
[ __ ] yeah baby
[ __ ] yeah baby
all right well target wow we love to see
it you know the holidays are coming what
are you getting me for christmas
oh something something's a surprise okay
okay it's a surprise okay
should we do a secret should we do a
secret santa for each other should we do
a gift gift exchange
oh that's sure why not um
why don't we have gabe come in
on our last
one before christmas and we can do a
gift exchange me and you is that sound
good love that that would work
that sounds fun i'd love to see you in
person and give you an embrace
in real life
get some of those going yeah
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i don't think it's a big role i think
it's one of those small
yeah yeah it's just you got a double or
18 a triple 24.
hell yeah you got all those prices on
lockdown
all right all right gabe well
you know
don't want to interfere with your
shopping
but it is friday so i'm glad to talk to
you is there work or school tomorrow
no work no school tomorrow oh [ __ ] no
[ __ ]
baby
it's friday baby
[Applause]
shopping friday baby
shopping friday
all right are you going to pick up some
white claws
probably
yeah good call
all right christmas all right you take
care you have a good holiday okay bud
yeah i have a good one
all right take care all right appreciate
you all right love to see you again
bye-bye all right all right
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] baby [ __ ]
oh i'm excited for it to do um
the gift exchange yeah that's a good
idea that's great better show up with
something good for me
because i'm gonna go for everything
for him i'm gonna buy him a rolex sack
wouldn't that be awesome
oof
that one's stung that stings huh that's
not even funny is it no that's that's
too cold man
that's some dark [ __ ] right there okay
yeah so um
what was it uh
what was it i was talking about before
gabe you were talking about your giant
turd left in your toilet oh yes
yeah the bathroom is in this communal
area
that like other people use who are in
our home
for example lena might use this toilet
right
um yeah she was there this morning yeah
she was there often this morning
and um
i made a mental note to get there first
thing in the morning to give a ride but
i didn't
and uh assuming somebody went in there
and had a rude awakening and this was
not a
third you would necessarily want to walk
in on not that any of them are but this
one in particular
was uh fairly girthy
and long was it solid at least yeah it
was good solid
it could be worse that's a little better
yeah if it was like a messy one yeah
she is usually here by now so it does
make me wonder i think she just fainted
or something
yeah so um house of goo here's a
headline for you
oh my god is this a real headline i love
this yep
house of gucci jared leto's horrendous
performance single-handedly ruins ridley
scott's movie holy [ __ ] serious this is
real oh my god that's awesome
that is so brutal i didn't think he was
that bad i thought he actually did a
good job well to be fair like isn't that
kind of the director's fault too in the
casting agent i didn't know that movie
was ridley scott actually and um
is there is there a director that's more
hit or miss than ridley scott there
can't be like he has some amazing movies
but he really has been pumping out some
stickers ridley scott what the [ __ ] has
even made recently isn't he like that
yeah i mean
like this dude he made like good sci-fi
was he actually just put this movie out
uh the last duel which was pretty decent
so it makes sense why this one was bad
right
he seems to be good at like sci-fi
fantasy and action and [ __ ] like that i
don't know what's this house of gucci
nonsense
with jared leto of all people damn he
could have cut he should just cast
russell crowe and everything seeing that
he made gladiator
love that movie
you know can i give an input on house of
gucci since we're on the topic sure i'd
love to hear your opinion so there's not
really spoiling anything but i don't
think anyone cares there's a sex scene
in the movie that is just so
it's a little much tell me everything
it's just adam driver is driving for
lack of a better term lady gaga and it's
just so intense and like it goes on for
so long it was a consensual moment right
right right of course um but it was just
it was just a much it was too much and
and so it felt like a little bit x-rated
you might say there were you didn't
really see
anything but
you saw them
too much yeah interesting i feel like
intimate sins are kind of like nobody
likes it
or is it just me no i totally agree
because it's like
for me when i watch something like that
i don't i mean sometimes the sex is
important to the story right but but
when it's not but it it can be like
implied like okay they went and they and
they are having something done
because like it's you know
i don't yeah i fully agree with you was
it important to the story that you see
they're long
absolutely not yes though
it was just it was and i was sitting
next to my grandmother oh yeah watch it
it's like nobody wants that'll affect
you
that'll affect it yeah that may have
peppered your experience a little bit
yeah that just went from you know it was
awful yo um somebody named jared donated
20 and said his eye jared joined me and
my cult hey how much he'd donate 20
bucks nice
pretty generous might be him yeah
if it was five i'd be like no that's not
the real that's weird yeah well welcome
welcome jared
welcome to machine gun
oh so anyway a little bit of top of the
show stuff
first of all shout out to our members
who we love so well shout out you make
it all happen you are our first line of
defense against the likes of ryan
kavanagh
you also get
that's true
um episodes early for example leftovers
members get it on saturday it's going up
on sunday and by the way it's a great
episode banger app best one yet
it is the best one yet it was it's right
really [ __ ] funny
yeah it was fun
also um
you get exclusive behind the scenes
is there one going up this week maybe
yeah it's ready to go what a guy what a
guy what a guy
so there you go okay here you are nice
extra content we love that and they're
great videos too i'll be straight up any
highlights you want to report from it
uh not really okay there's a really long
drawn out sex scene between abe and zach
members
and i do get a pretty gnarly fight in
this one so oh yeah there you go
there's um high drama a lot of people
are always asking where's behind the
scenes one through seven that's on the
highlights channel that was before this
was a members thing i keep seeing that
come up sorry
just so you guys know
also
you
the deadline is quick approaching
to get on this h3h3 holiday march 100 of
the
money goes to the crew
oh
you know so what what's the cutoff here
of december 5th uh yeah which i believe
is sunday oh so it's coming up clearly
if you do want any of this beautiful go
to h3h3shop.com should be clear on that
too that the december 5th cutoff is the
last day that they will guarantee it
will arrive by christmas
it's possible it could still come if you
order after that especially if you live
in the united states international it's
probably a stretch yeah i think that's
probably just in the u.s right i have to
guess do you have any intel on which one
of these are selling
the highest seller is the one you're
looking at right now followed very
closely by the advent calendar those two
are are selling like this one and the oh
okay great yeah those are awesome yeah
those are so cute well there you go a3
shop.com 100 to the crew who we love so
well
and teddy fresh just dropped a new
collection
yesterday
and unfortunately
this piece for example isn't going to
come out till next week because the
whole world is [ __ ] yeah
supply chain supply chain baby god damn
it
those ports
but next week you think regular i think
so yeah that set is so cool
i love it the full birthday my [ __ ]
god cam
what do we get from the camera what is
cam doing oh [ __ ] alfredo walking in the
bathroom this morning for breakfast no
that's disgusting bro no don't even
[ __ ] joke about that
because i you know what i'm not gonna
say don't even say it
get that out of here pretty funny
freedom foreign
yeah but what you can buy now
is this beautiful classic thermal zip
hoodie yeah pretty cool it's got that
thermal inline
which is like you know that really nice
thermal material you wear the long
sleeves yeah so that's really cozy and
nice
holiday uh hoodie
um
the marled
sweater
beautiful huh it's a nice one i think so
um oh god it's gotta be a better way to
do this
um
this one's doing really good we are the
world
we are the world that's michael jackson
right so maybe not that one i love it
it's got a like a panel that's knitted
with the bears yeah
there
we are the world we are the children
children oh see why is he gonna go there
the uh
the ultimate bob dylan moment if you
recall oh when he's just like tripping
he doesn't he doesn't know the words and
he's like
yeah shout out to bobby
yeah so um
did you guys see this or was dan
covering it with bob dylan
no i think it's off mix stitch sweater
um
ski jacket beautiful restock oh that's a
restaurant from last year
and
the this is the shirt i've been wearing
a lot love it oh there's only the large
sizes left in that one but if you're a
big boy or
a
girl grab that and then you know there's
there's this and this and this oh this
one people really like
yeah we've got we put beads on it yeah
kind of hard to tell or maybe i can open
it
yeah it's beads ladies and gentlemen
what do you think about that huh
beads bees
it's in beads damn it
and the hat i'm wearing right now
that's it head on over
teddyfresh.com and there'll be more next
week yep
thank you thank you thank you
all right we got a lot to get to here
today a lot of fun a great show
first of all we talked at great length
about
mr beast being potentially being sued by
the creator right right uh yes
well what's interesting is i was
scrolling my tick tock feed yesterday
yeah and on my tick tock feed came the
creator of squid games
commenting
on all these youtubers
recreating it and this gives us our
answer 100
what do you think of the um uh
youtube gamers out there that are
creating their own squid games
why are you going to put copyrighted
music on this like all right so
unnecessary
i watched some of it i loved it
you have to promote the show too so
there we go
more people do it
there you have it
[Applause]
that's the perfect answer it is that is
the perfect thing i just and i came upon
it just
uh by chance i love it he says i love it
i watch some of it i hope people do more
of it it promotes the show it's awesome
he was actually talking about the h3
squid game specifically
he's like that mr beast guy he ain't got
nothing on that one
oh should i also give an update about
the dinosaur sweater oh yes
so today
we made contact with gary
let me give a little background here
dinosaur sweater gone but not forgotten
lots of controversy about that people
are well i
anyway it was a design that uh
was taken from this guy gary kennedy's
knitting books
and we've got in touch with them
sorry so go ahead you
well then today there was um
a zoom call with someone on our team and
him and he was super down to
license it officially and we're probably
gonna work more together too so oh yeah
we're gonna
happy ending yeah
great probably put it up next week after
we you know so we got gary involved and
he even he's like you can use my
knitting patterns
uh what do you mean well he's like you
can use my work he said you can license
my work yes yeah yeah like anything he
started sending us like all kinds of
things
that's more stuff yeah i think let's go
you like the brand apparently what's
really interesting about this guy is
that he made a killing on these knitting
books back in the 90s he retired like
super young because apparently he was
like i didn't know people were making so
much money on damn knitting book but
he's like a knitting god
and he just like retired it was he's
just like chilling he's not even that
old like damn gary
yeah
he sounds super cool
chill great guy
love gary sick
so happy ending
very happy i'm actually so excited
so we're gonna put those up in cedar
rapids
that's where he is now that's where
you're retired
um so there's been a bit of a drama on
leftovers which you guys haven't seen
yet
zach has been telling us that he's 6-3
[Music]
zach
he's been telling us all that he's 6-3
and i don't deny that zach is a tall man
but hassan says he's 6'4
and then zach was like wow you're a
three xl i can't believe you're so big
whatever he was like
zach was simping for abe for his dawn i
think i think we'd be friends yeah
tall guy energy
tall guys just stick together like that
sure
yeah so i said zach why don't you come
over here and stand next to his son
because
something's not adding up well zach came
and stood next to hassan and i was like
hassan
was towering over
and i was like
is there a picture of that it's on the
video it's on the episode it'll be on
the leftovers yeah okay so and i was
like
something's not right because he's more
than an inch taller than you
oh
my god and then i stood next to you and
i was like you're not even that much
taller than me ultimately well i'll tell
you 5 11. yeah i think i'm a little
taller than you didn't you guys see when
we stood face to face and i was like not
that much taller
yeah i saw it i was surprised i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna comment on anybody's
physical appearance after uh last week
oh well last week remember i got
cancelled for saying that you looked
like the same side
for calling me a father
you're a fat person check the tape check
the tape
all right go off king
step up here
step step over here so we're we're going
to measure him
we're going to get to the bottom
just measure me too i'll take my shoes
off as well
by the way for everyone who thinks this
is mean zack's a tall legend he's a
beautiful man he's got a perfect body
don't feel bad they're short people in
the world
so
you know what it's like it's like stolen
valor it's like if you're already tall
you already have the tall
you already won the lottery on that why
you got a lot you shouldn't have to lie
and say oh i'm six seven when you're
actually six two
you know all right but so here let's do
first of all let's just stand
facing each other
i mean you're obviously taller but here
ethan take the handle from you
oh
you see like you're obviously clearly
taller
but like treating this like but you're
like two inches taller than me i would
say
okay
all right so hold this let's get out the
measuring tape i mean i i have a size 13
shoe
okay well i mean i don't doubt that your
cock's huge so
[Laughter]
if we want to go down that road
all right
he's measuring me now
hi
hi ap
hello hila hi sorry
who's the official measurer though i
don't know if it should be me but
okay zach put your back to the tape
okay
so i wish we had some intent wait you
got to get it straight otherwise you're
going to add an extra inch to that okay
you see what i'm seeing
six one [ __ ]
to be fair last time i was at the doctor
he did say i was 6'3 so the [ __ ] lied
to me he was just being nice
yeah the [ __ ] doctor
lied to me i'm still over six foot i
know that's my point you're already tall
you're already a tall guy i was just
going off with a flex on us all what was
the final measurement six six one six
one all right which is great
i'm content that's tall the people
submit some girls might say that's a
perfect height for a guy how tall are
you i'm 5 11. should we should we make
sure okay well if i'm if i put youtube
he's throwing shade around here man i
guess if i
i guess that's only fair right
throwing shade around right now
just tall think tall thoughts think tall
thoughts
think tall thoughts what is this think
tall thoughts
tall thoughts
he's got it mike here i'll announce it
you're almost six foot
no way
i see the measuring tape all crooked
[Laughter]
no no no i'll take that i'll take that
very though
i guess i'm taller than i thought and
you're shorter than you thought huh
how about that dude look at that my and
i have tiny hands and you have huge
manhands so
[Laughter]
height isn't everything
but it's a lot when you're dating
i'm just saying you it's like stolen
valor
you're already tall
great kids to be fair i was told i was
6'3 so apologies
all right
you may not have the doctor once told me
i was seven foot
[Laughter]
that's interesting though i mean do you
wear super thick shoes
no i wear vans every day okay that's
that's that's fair
i wear vans um yeah see six one is kind
of astronomical
how does that feel does that change your
self perception not really i mean i'm
always known and will be known as a big
guy a lot of accusations of rigging by a
b
well i thought it was 511 so like i'll
take 511.
recount
ethan cheat well it wouldn't be just for
zach it wouldn't have been ethan to be
fair it may have been half an inch off
whatever
yeah it's fine crooked tape i may have
been standing on my tippy toes a little
bit
but just not enough for you to notice
you're you're 5 12.
you're almost 6 foot you're 5 12.
okay
what the [ __ ] was that
you're deep in thought
that's very interesting that anyone else
want to step up let's get some true
height measurements out here
pretty interesting when you because
everybody i wonder
you want to do it yeah okay all right
does pregnancy do anything to your
height
no no
the baby stretch your body out
ela's tall but there was always a
argument between me and ela a playful
gesting between who's taller
have you been seeing all those memes
people have been doing
yeah like the baby ones are making these
super oh we should grab some of those
they're fine yeah
um
laptop
all right
all right this is uh here let me get out
of the way
[Music]
okay so we're pulling it in now let me
i'm gonna make sure she gets this fair
shake here
you wanna stand on your tippy toes a
little bit
okay should we go a little bit forward
you gotta go
just so we can
okay
um so here let me kick this forward a
little bit
put it up a little more you know
somewhere around there what is that 60
70 69 inches what does that mean
no she's not five nine
i think it's more
i'd say she's more five ten
five nine and a half wait
five nine that's five nine
yeah five nine or five ten maybe
sixty nine are you standing up as
straight as you can wait am i like way
taller than you she's pregnant so she's
like you think her body gets compressed
by the way
like a [ __ ] uh
it's not scientific wait hold on hold on
here here let's stand face to face come
here am i that am i that much taller oh
my god dude i feel so tall lately i'm a
monster
look how [ __ ] tall i am bro bro sure
anything you want look how [ __ ] tall
i am dude
god bro
i'm standing just flat on my heels bro
what happened you have massive hands
with the surgery right i grew i got
taller right you did have that surgery
look at check my feet
i got it what's the check my feet that
shit's on the ground bro
wow
this thing worked out well for me
it's awesome
getting fat made me taller
interesting how that works
growing in every direction av you want
to do it
are you scared to know the truth
you don't want to offend the short king
oh sorry i said i don't want to offend
the short no i'm just they don't like
the measurements they say that we're
height
judging based on height
what i'm short numerical value is that
what you're trying to say sure people
feel bad for being short i think the uh
the lens was distorting reality a little
bit because
you take a look at this the new trends
on the subreddit so edit me you know
tiny little
short king
[Laughter]
nothing wrong with being short king
short king's paul [ __ ] mad tale dude
what are you talking about
ever heard of napoleon
maybe your mic's not on about
it it wasn't it was a moment ago
people are saying you're six you're five
two maybe and that's why you don't want
to get i'm actually five three
that's why you don't want
people are asking for olivia's height
i'm five five five six
no the thing is what i women have no no
yeah i'm like
i don't wanna be tall i don't wanna be
short i wanna be right there right there
in the middle olivia hassan told me
yesterday that i'm a lot taller than he
expected and i'm just going to go out
with that
he said because he's kind of like a
backhanded car
well no you're saying when i saw the
camera i thought you were short
and he goes no one here is short when i
said maybe because i have the wide angle
i'm the only one that uses it now maybe
it's not short i don't think you're sure
i just i cannot believe how massive
hassan is it's currently well he's
actually six four yeah no he's he's i
mean he's but his legs are just oh you
actually got the moment
that i feel like at that angle it
doesn't even
put it into justice yeah
he's he's a big guy like huge anyway the
episode is great
uh this weekend so make sure to catch
that thank you thank you peace and love
peace and love peace in love
okay that was fun let's ride
the thing is if i wear shoes which i
never do i feel like so freaking tall
like you put on two inches easy i'm
cruising around like six one
that's pretty sick time to get some j's
my dog
i gotta get those robert downey junior
shoes where he like secretly adds six
inches have you seen those wow i hate
that
they look normal i don't believe that it
looks normal it does they're crazy you
wear them with long pants the platform
show me that [ __ ] it's crazy
it literally adds six inches to your
height
like what
i did a whole surgery for that
that's like the miracle bra for men it's
like you get home
you got to take off the shoes sometime
is this them you know what i'm saying
that's yeah that's a pair of them you
see how deep that goal is bro that looks
like oh that just looks like the healed
conversation yeah we're women we don't
wear that but you can but you can
exaggerated oh yeah there's like an
extra wait women
yeah so they're like high heels but
they're like stealth yeah they're like
wet yeah they're they're elevator shoes
that's another term
like anybody is trying to hide them he
is
definitely
right
yeah usually yeah there's a lot of
people i wouldn't even i wouldn't think
twice about it looking at those unless i
was aware
because they're sneakily add like an
extra three inches
look at these souls kim said i sent this
one
i mean not that listen my thing is you
should be confident and beautiful in
your own skin we love everybody
short king skinny kings fat kings
everybody we love the bodies
but we can make fun of robert downey
because he's a celeb and also
it's okay to be comfortable in your own
skin and be a short king
now what the [ __ ] is this
i guess it's just that the soul is it's
like an extra fatty yeah
is he that short
he wore them a lot when they were doing
the civil war movie when it was him
first captain america i wonder if the
marvel made him do it i wonder because
captain america towers and chris evans
so that kind of made them face to face
whenever they do like the interviews and
stuff
chris evans height see this this is just
the interesting character to come back
this is just interesting
inside baseball stuff i mean chris evans
is six foot he's not super tall but you
know tall
uh robert downey is six five nine is
that with or without miracle shoes yeah
hard to say right
that's short king right there though
five nine's not that bad it's not bad at
all come on don't show it don't tell
shane people
six one okay okay just throwing up i'm
just covering my bases
if five nine is the average height of an
american male so he's actually right on
target i take that back
thank you
i apologize for his remarks
on his behalf
um we are uh already at break time
are you freaking serious bro
i'm
i'm dead serious wait what is this one
him and uh jude law
look the same height
right
so what's happening here
how tall is jude law
compare their souls okay
cam is going csi on [ __ ] robert
no it's funny yo look at this [ __ ] bro
yeah wait that's a [ __ ] okay i didn't
know they did this what a trickery
is it flat inside or it goes down no
it's wet oh that's gotta be so
uncomfortable right
i imagine like more comfortable than
heels but obviously less comfortable
than sneaking so down so down he's
walking around in high heels all day
yeah he's looking like a 2000s
uh converse [ __ ] what a snap
[Laughter]
what a snack he is
yeah the heel difference is pretty well
oh jude law is five ten okay let's move
on i thought you law was super tall
all right geez i'm getting caught in the
height vortex apparently
okay i'm sending more oh god i gotta
look at them oh wait here's the unedited
version
super tall down he's like five he's like
six five
oh yeah
all right sorry let's just [ __ ] move
on with the show
and thank our sponsors real fast
thank you to raycon
by now you've probably seen about a
thousand gift guides for the holiday
season gifts for moms gifts for guys
gifts for neighbors cousins dogs you can
study all those gift guides and shop at
tens of different places or you can
start shopping at raycon and get a gift
everybody will love raycon wireless
earbuds
these are great earbuds they're
comfortable
they're slick
sounds great
what else can you say what else you want
from your earbuds raycon gives you
amazing audio quality wherever you go
whether you use them to pump up wind
down work out
or just go to work
they'd be useful for anyone on your list
even better for you
they start at half the price of other
premium audio brands and with the latest
model you get three new sound profiles
to make sure everything you're listening
to sounds its best with just the right
amount of bass you've got pure mode
balance mode bass mode
and raycons are available in five
stylish colors so you can pick a perfect
one for everyone on your list with free
shipping returns gifting is easier than
ever yeah and they're they're got all
these like little ear adapter molds real
nice real soft
oh there you go look at that eh snug
the holidays are coming up faster than
you think and now is the time to knock
that gift list and avoid the last
minutes uh shipping scramble especially
because right now my listeners will get
15 off site-wide with code holiday at
byraycon.com
h3ad go to byraycon.com
h3ad and use the code holiday2day to get
15 off your entire raycon order by
raycon.com h3ad thank you thank you
thank you thank you by smelling those
calzones
do you know about the calzone zelo
you're going to find out
um thank you to mint mobile this holiday
season the best deal on wireless can
only be found at mint mobile right now
when you switch to mint mobile and buy
any three month plan you'll get another
three months for free and as the first
company to sell premium wireless service
online only mint mobile lets you order
from home and save a ton with phone
plans starting at just 15 bucks a month
dan
dan uses mobile i do
i switch from one of the big
boys
in town and uh you know them
you hate them yep
you get the same thing
for a fraction of the price
the same it's literally the same
literally the same thing and it's just
way cheaper
you know um i love mint mobile because
you know it's super well dan loves mint
mobile because it's super fast service
and it's
without the high cost of other providers
that's right that's right
that's right you don't have to think
about it dude
best mint mobile's best offer of the
year is here for a limited time by any
three-month plan and get three months
for free by going online
only in limiting tradition nutritional
costs of retail
mint mobile
passes significant savings onto you and
all plans come with unlimited talk
contacts high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network you see
that's the thing they don't tell you
these guys all use the same network
or there's like two networks or maybe
three but no it's like they're all the
same main carriers so it's the same [ __ ]
with mim mobile choose the amount of
monthly data that's right for you
and stop paying for data that you never
use you can use your phone with any
mobile plan and keep your same phone
number along with all your existing
contacts
switch to mint mobile
get the premium wireless service
starting at just 15 freaking dollars a
month dude
15.
uh for a limited time buy any three
month mobile plan to get three months
for free by going to mintmobile.com h3
that's mint mobile.com slash h3 cut your
wireless bill to 15 bucks a month
admin mobile.com h3 thank you
okay
okay
okay all right let's get into some good
stuff
so i'm getting into some good stuff
right now you know what i'm saying you
know what i'm saying okay so all right
what's the deal with yeah cameron's been
manifesting
um
he's been obsessed with
my boy
he's been obsessed with calzones
he keeps talking about these buffalo
chicken
calzones
then what kind of italian puts buffalo
chicken in a calzone
it doesn't make any sense
well sam brought it upon herself
to make it oh my god and you basted
these
holy [ __ ] where you made it yes sam made
these
so if you guys ever doubted manifesting
was real
cam manifested this [ __ ] wow
buffalo
chicken calzone made by so powerful let
me just take a bite i got a veggie one
epic oh my god cheers what is in this
hmm buffalo chicken
it's so [ __ ] good
wow cam's joining us we love you sam
thank you
oh my god sam what the [ __ ]
thank you sam this is [ __ ] amazing
how'd you make this yeah tell us about
the process
[Music]
[Laughter]
so
i make the dough
the dough has to rise for a while and
then while it's rising i just make the
filling
and then i just you know
throw it all together
and then it's i made like a herb butter
for the top
unbelievable does she cook like this at
home ian yeah she's a wizard oh my god
holy [ __ ] this is amazing oh it blows my
mind she's she's so good
[ __ ] bro
i feel like it's worth saying that this
is sam's second time making a calzone
and it's a masterpiece again like the
first time was last weekend and it was
it was awesome it's just good now so
thank you very much sam oh my god oh so
that's what was in ian's story
when i thought that you guys went and
bought it
i didn't realize sam made it
wow
pam doesn't buy those
it's a masterpiece i gotta say not as
good as the peppermint mash though
not as good
oh i believe you yeah why do you even
remind me of that
[Laughter]
that was like haunting me for days
afterwards i would just like get
like acid flashbacks
to the [ __ ]
peppermint mashed potato [ __ ]
when i brushed my teeth it was a little
bit jarring right for the first time
totally
so by the way let's talk about some
some calf calf slash and also our
favorite keemstar
um
there's some there's a lot of follow-up
from the we did this mega
lawsuit episode by the way i saw a lot
of people saying that maybe i should
make a h3 video about it
what do you guys think about that idea i
love that idea
i think it's a really good idea
really everyone likes it huh
he would get so many people talking
about it in the first place especially
since it would be like a comeback video
too
well it's not a comeback video i'm not
making videos there
but it's like
you came back for a second and then
you're gonna go away again yeah exactly
just like quick like got your hat and
then you're gone again
you guys think i should do that
the thing is um
maybe i'll do it over there i don't know
what is it but i guess those videos have
more power for some reason well short
more consumable we made a three-hour
podcast yeah yeah right like nobody's
gonna have to like read it
so
it used to be those videos will get
posted to our videos
right you go to the top of the homepage
and then
media picks it up and other kinds of
people see it right
interesting
maybe i should do that
gotta think of how to make it like funny
and entertaining and stuff
maybe it's a project for over the break
ela
a solo project
like the old days
yep yep
[ __ ]
one last ride
i mean [ __ ] if not now
i mean there's so much to say
about ryan
i wonder if we should have someone play
ryan in reenactments of his greatest
crimes
fourth lawsuit incoming oh yeah well i'm
clear with the lawyers you know
but like if we had someone playing ryan
maybe we could hire a craigslist guy who
looks like him i actually know someone
that would be really good but he's in
jail right now
harvey all right yeah
that was really good
you got me dude maybe they'll make an
exception i don't know
we can apply see if we can get a
specialized
temporarily temporarily for harvey yeah
he's probably dangerous society
he might have to be cuffed in the video
in the reenactment
our mom's got like a really fat redhead
guy
who's just a total man
the chewing yeah that's pretty bad
you gotta choose between chewing and
talking
i refuse to shoot
shredders really wanting this there you
go the music the music bed helps it'll
kind of
drown out some of the chew as loud as
you want
careful all right i'm sorry andrew
santino people are saying
oh aren't you oh my god
it's not a bad suggestion but andrew
santino's like handsome
oh we can give them prosthetics to make
them all [ __ ] up
a coming back of family in new york
that would be really fun me father come
a forward man in the water
like a judge was like did you really
falsify a document accusing your
ex-president of
yeah president of the company of the
yeah right of sh
and i'll be like oh
whoops
i dated a gigan
i just depicted he's he's a mario
brother
like an italian plumber
ryan did you really just get
did you are you driving with alcohol
in your system again while your license
on on probation oops i did it again
[Laughter]
he's so cool chet hanks
bobby lee playing the judge
all star cat that's all right
i'm just taking suggestions and taking
suggestions from the chat see man will
be the bailiff why don't we get um chris
uh
[Laughter]
why don't we get chris uh pratt to play
uh
right ryan i just got to play all the
roles really i feel like if anyone's
gonna play ryan you should play ryan
that's true mm-hmm yeah that's right man
yeah do we have a role for vin diesel
oh
was the babysitter that didn't allegedly
get paid
that's just dizzling a wig
he was the lead in that movie where he
oh yeah
family
family family family family
he loves family family family family
family family family family family
family family family
because i'm always off and delayed we
love that for you
yo vin diesel
uh the fastest some of the faster
furious movies were um
done under relativity media
someone saved me
um
yeah i gotta think about that i really
want to do it really good so it's
entertaining you know sure it's not just
me bitching being like this guy's a
douche
although those videos do well too
i already did that for three hours
though so i don't know if there's any
new information there
content nuke did really well and that
was what like 25 minutes a content nuke
on ryan cavanaugh
i mean it's not really because he
doesn't have content so it's it's sort
of a different but i just mean that uh
structure and and sort of tone and
everything
people really enjoyed
and yeah i mean what they were like 30
minutes roughly the first one was like
45 minutes was it really that long yeah
well maybe it's a bad example then it
just got age rest or well got like
mature rated so right yeah 46 minutes
all right never mind
all right i think i'll start working on
the script
[Applause]
so i guess look forward to that round of
applause
um
so guys there's some updates on ryan
cavanaugh we talked at great length
about it and i've seen the complaint
emily baker did a great video on it
shout out to her family i watched the
whole thing yeah what was your
impression
um
well
i felt more confident for you having you
know gone over in detail the entire
complaint um you know i i you had
explained
what the scope of the lawsuit was it it
really is purely restricted to this
whole thing with the variety article and
everything
and i mean i'm not a lawyer but the
impression that i got from her and just
you know
i guess just a layperson's impression
is that
his complaint really is with variety it
should not be with you um you know if he
feels that that article is defamatory
then that his issue is with them not
with somebody who's just repeating it
and what i thought was interesting too
is in the lawsuit they cite
like
so many examples of us talking about it
and not a single one
is it not predicated by
as written in variety alleged you know
what i mean like i have never right
claimed ryan is running a ponzi scheme
right never yep
how would i know that yeah
you are just repeating what is out there
and so
you know
when things go to court anything can
happen so that's what people always say
so i i guess
you know you can't feel 100 confident
about it but it does seem like he has an
uphill battle proving that what you did
was defamation yeah but the thing is
like
if you read his complaint you know
they're looking for war so it's going to
be right it's going to be bitter
and there's certain stuff in there which
they included just to be douches which
i'll read
but if you guys want to read my full
statement if you go to if you type into
google
rank kavanaugh
which i suggest doing that instead of
the whole name because it's so long
we're at the top no that's not it
sorry about that
well we're at like four here let me do
an incognito
um
oh yeah
let's see where it is no but there's
been a lot of movement which clearly is
you know google recognizing
that this page is relevant
to his name
and again what are they going to go sue
google if you have a problem with that
you know what i mean i don't i don't
control their algorithm right like what
the [ __ ]
google do you know how closely google
protects their algo algorithm it's like
their most prized asset
let's google some isis videos
when did i say that
do you really want me to do that
let's go i mean he lost the boss
i don't know when did they say that and
why
yeah so here it is
and then obviously enjoy the website and
everything on here but if you go to
statement and click statement
you can read my whole statement
with citations or well i guess we're
gonna add links love you did all this
with all the embedding and everything it
looks great yeah
yeah love love
love he's our webmaster
thank you thank you
so if you guys want to read this
statement in full
i'm i'm trying to go to the home
yeah you should talk about the
tweet links that i added
so if you go to home
or wait you want to say statement yeah
yeah so there's
we first have that one ryan cavanaugh
one of hollywood's most prominent film
financers was arrested for drunk driving
speeding and driving with a suspension
license in october that was by the new
york times write a direct quote from
their article
yeah so you can tweet that out oh it hit
like automatically i'm not looking for
incognito so it's not like it
automatically fills in
yeah so you can just hit that tweet
right there
and at the bottom you have another one
that shares this article
there we go
uh fantastic oh so you sharing this
statement
that was the main one that's very good
yeah so if you want to click this and
share the article that would help
educate the masses
and it's just
it's just user-friendly uh website
widgets right i mean
yeah of course
[Laughter]
so there you have it good progress there
on the website it's coming along really
nicely
oh we got a ryan cavanaugh tweet what is
this this yeah i just found this one
this is pretty beautiful
pretty ironic america is built on free
speech right
so people should embrace others opinions
even if i think that you look like
harvey weinstein you really haven't
embraced that opinion wait you're logged
into the podcast right now you should
retweet that
[Music]
[Laughter]
quote tweet
what about the opinion
that you look like harvey weinstein
you know
okay but there's one secret tweet
there's one tweet by the way can you do
me a favor and retweet that from my
phone
okay but there's one coming up that we
found that is so good and some people
discovered it and were commenting on it
and i was really hoping he wouldn't
erase it and it looks like he didn't and
i'm so [ __ ] happy he didn't oh yeah
this is ryan cavanaugh the great mind
someone asked him in 2016 august 12.
um
and just to give some
just to give some like uh setting to
this this was when me too started
happening right
so
uh it was after
several accusations started to come out
in the media about him i would say it
was before the like massive uh coverage
really well what's the first accusation
because i want to be
accurate uh
i know that there was one
prominent one in 2015 which is obviously
prior to this um 2017 is when his whole
empire started to collapse under the
weight of it so this was between those
two events but it was certainly
after
uh he had been accused
of you're sure about that i want to make
sure we're well right in 2015
uh yeah well let's put let's who accuses
him of 2015
i'll tell you right now it was a italian
model from new york okay good so this is
out there
so so this twitter user asks ryan
kavanagh
with respect do you consider harvey and
bob weinstein friends of yours
okay
frank kavanagh
responds
he says brilliant creative minds
then he specifically mentions harvey by
name
never underestimate harvey he is a
survivor
very unfortunate choice what do you like
about what do you like about survivor
very survivor
what is the surviving
these accusations being leveled against
him so i'm going to retweet this no wait
you think that's what he means
what else could he mean he's a survivor
of what uh you know the ups and downs of
the industry
yeah because
this is before me too no
yeah well again there was an article in
the new york times in 2015 uh about
harvey weinstein so that was the
beginning of it also we should say
that
it was
widely considered an open secret in
hollywood yeah that harvey weinstein i
don't care about open secrets i care
about this woman had already made a
public accusation yes new york times
article 2015 uh was sort of the the
beginning of the so what torrent of
accusations harvey weinstein
the biggest most famous king maker movie
producer of all time
what could he be referring to when he
calls him a survivor
again if you want to give him the
benefit of the doubt it would be
the ups and downs okay so so i'm not
going to say here's what i'm going to
say but obviously using that term
survivor in this context is a huge
cringe so well because you would call
the victims of essay survivors right
right and i'll say something like love
to see king supporting kings
or what's a better response do you guys
think
because that's fine i mean i'm not
saying anything he's king sporting again
[Laughter]
i i
i think it speaks for itself i think you
could just retweet it without comments
and
uh film yeah
you're okay dan
here's the timeline this is actually put
it in context for us sorry i gotta
finish chewing
blame sam
okay so 2015
italian model
reported him to the nypd
right
and then another one in 2015
2016
this tweet took place
august 12 2016. this was yeah this
these allegations in 16 were shortly
after that tweet the 2016. didn't erase
it by the way he could have erased it
yeah but dan's right 2017 uh october is
when new york times made an article and
that's where things started really when
it like really fell apart for him
um
now
who knows if ryan was aware of the
previous accusations not we we we don't
know
i mean i'm sure he would say he was do
you think starvie's a survivor we know
that right
we have entered the choosing ladies and
gentlemen
um a lot of people in the chat are
saying just retweet no quote tweet just
retweet i think you should say if you
don't believe in yourself who are you
going to believe in
or love yourself first
because he is supporting himself in that
tweet obviously
so retweet so here give me my phone
i'll just retweet
no comment added
yeah maybe i'll make a comment
underneath it like king's supporting
kings that can't be defamatory he's
literally i'm calling him a king
best of the best somebody said best of
the best
that's pretty funny too you guys believe
this tweet though how [ __ ] crazy is
that pretty cringe
it's pretty cringe
that one's really good too the
america is built on free speech
wait why am i not seeing it
on my feed you're blocked you're blocked
i think yeah because you're blocked oh
no
that's so [ __ ] up that was unfortunate
that is unfortunate
really
if if you quote tweet it with the
podcast account and then retweet that
right you should be able to wait really
that's pretty high level antics
okay let's try that
let's see hacking twitter
king uh just well i have to say
something
king's supporting certain things
what
hollywood producer things only for
someone
i don't know just hollywood producer
things you are who you're from i'll just
say ryan cavanaugh thinks harvey is a
survivor
that's factual
dry
there's literally like no okay i like
that that's like it's literally just a
reinterpretation of what our rewording
of what he said yeah ryan kavanagh
says harvey weinstein says
harvey
weinstein
is a survivor you okay with that ela
i mean i i think just retweeting is fine
we did but
the thing is that we're doing trickery
because i can't
retweet it from my account unless we
how about just like hashtag tweets that
aged poorly
okay we're good now
kings supporting kings
that one i'm not sure about how can that
be defamatory well if it's
not defamatory but i don't know maybe
it's not that good yeah
don't don't quote tweet from your
account
because then it won't show
the original tweet if that makes sense
oh that's so interesting that you know
yeah you need to just retweet it okay
that's what happened to what's its name
the then so dude
jordan then you just quote tweet
yourself
yeah
great done the original one so then it's
just a retweet you know
all right yeah here's the original tweet
pretty interesting stuff i wonder what
else is in his twitters
i mean we have him
i mean damn
that shit's pretty good
somebody said are we gonna workshop the
title next
of the episode
harvey i mean well we could go with i
think harvey weinstein lands you an
instant yellow
yeah unfortunately
would be a good title though
let's see
yeah he loves him he calls him brilliant
gave him a big old kiss on the head man
he loves harvey mm-hmm i mean i don't i
think that's a fair statement that he
loved or at least loved harvey
he kissed his old master i don't kiss
by the way i don't i don't go around
just smooching people on the head
ever
i mean
like other than my son you know heart
like heart like ryan kevin or harvey
weinstein if you look at these photos of
them together
yeah
we've worked together for years you've
never smooched me like this is this is
love and adoration that's
oh
what do you know it's our web are
this is our subreddit
i mean like when have you ever kissed
someone on the dome like that especially
an oily greasy troll like rv
i'll kiss the guys and the beautiful
i'll give you a big beautiful kiss
oh
boy
i learned hassan taught me that harvey
weinstein had like a mangled genitals
yeah
i guess part of his pathology no like
his genitals were like um deformed gang
green green dick
for real
like super like huh just i don't even i
can't even imagine so i would google
gangrene dick but yeah probably maybe
i'll just look for my own i won't put it
on screen oh god
you really want to see that well i'm
curious what they what you know
hi i'm dick tip
green green
penis
that's a good one i didn't know you
could get green green in your penis
oh my god wait what
wait you guys can see that no i looked
it up also
oh
surgery videos yeah and i feel
a little bit upset about what i just saw
apparently the hell okay
looks like he was attacked by a [ __ ]
shark dude i would say shoot me in the
head this is
[ __ ] horrible out of everything we've
looked up the gaping hands
this is by far the worst that can't be
why do you still have it
up i closed it i'm fascinated no we
don't have it
i closed it no love can see it on a b
screen over there
both of you young and stuff
everyone's saying crotch rot
definitely that's what it looks like it
looks like he has a flesh-eating
virus on his dick
by the way so this is this is uh listen
to this hello the disgrace
traumatizing well and then yeah so they
thought it was part of his pathology
that like he was expressing
um
his like anger on these women in that
way and make forcing them to deal with
that
pretty [ __ ]
very [ __ ]
listen to this the disgraced movie
moguls deformed genitals is the result
of a life-threatening bacterial
infection known as uh fournier's
gangrene
what so he yeah he had gangrene this is
well-known yeah
it was discovered in the during the
trial right one of the girls testified
and then it became like oh my god yeah
she said she felt bad for him because oh
yeah she said she felt bad after she saw
his penis just looks like a like a
perpetual open wound
like that must be very these are
horrible some of them just look like
someone took a shotgun straight to their
sack
i spent a lot of time on rotten.com as a
kid i i've had my share i think i'll be
uh setting this one out
nothing will ever compare to what mean
you saw that one day on e [ __ ]
[Laughter]
nothing will ever beat that that [ __ ]
me up
for the rest of the day
yeah for life maybe even uh can you
elaborate it was a woman in a stiletto a
really high sharp stone let's talk about
this guy
she stomped on his member and it went
through yeah
like she was stomping on it and he was
like oh yeah like they were into it but
then it busted through and then
dude that was not a good situation whoa
yeah
yeah
thanks you done describing it i'm done
yeah okay
were you plugging your ears yeah i just
don't even want to hear it
do you think everyone in the chat just
looked up
crotch or whatever it's called gangrene
based off of what i'm seeing in the chat
yes a large majority look at google
analytics tomorrow
gang green penis is uh off the charts
some some marketing person somewhere is
like there's a huge market here
uh oh
we gotta get on this green green penis
of craze
gen z is really into
cnn
the local news
the kids latest craze is gang green
penis
okay so moving on anyways yeah moving on
with peace and love
um we have a lot of great cav cav
updates today
delete me from this conversation yes
don't worry jack well
so this one's shaq shaquille o'neal sent
me this
psych
fight
no no laughter for that tricked me man i
thought that was fun
man
um let's see so cav cab's post he posted
this if you know anything about
instagram this is like the dumbest post
nobody cares it doesn't mean it's just
horrible right
got 58 000 likes pretty sweet people
really are engaged with this content
but his
from the day before or
this was uh after an hour later or a few
hours later 26 likes
that seems organic maybe those 55 000
people just went to sleep or something
yeah they didn't see weird hour yeah
well okay well then tell me what you
think about this one
i'm not making any accusation i'm simply
putting what's publicly available check
this out do the math on this okay
so this post
okay hold on
this this post has 29 000 likes on it
but it only has
2106 views hmm
how does that happen what does that mean
i would call that um
weird
yeah that is weird you're right
those
maybe they're like time travelers but i
do wonder how it's possible to get 29
000 likes on a post
and yet only 2 106 people watch it hmm
[Laughter]
well we got to put a good end to it
because when we stopped at wrong times
right yeah do the choir director so how
should i how should i convey it in a way
and stop like that yeah
he was afraid of that happening that's
exactly what happened we all stopped and
then love was just like family
family family family family family
family
stop
thank you
well that'll work
uh
this one is so weird bruh love found
this one and i just i still don't know
if this really trailer love you want to
talk about this one
um what are we talking about the nft
trailer nft that's right yeah so i guess
what's his name bobby bobby something is
he's uh employed by trailer do you
believe he should i do believe the other
day let's make sure here on this
well i said that because i am
sure but i'm not legally sure
that makes sense
well you should say something like um
you should my understanding is
that he
is
affiliated with trill
[Laughter]
because you're saying that's your
understanding your understanding could
be wrong
yeah we'll just google his name is he
what's his full name
right i wasn't prepared to
you you talk about it and i'll find his
name i don't know [ __ ] about it okay
i didn't know we were gonna bring this
so what happened to your screen
oh my god it's flipped we talked about
chilling
i can fix this
uh-huh almost
90 more degrees okay uh it's all flipped
hang on i can fix this
so anyway
yep
yeah it looks good
[Laughter]
i was saying
this is almost too insane to i just i
have
i'm doubting it because it's so crazy
oh so
he's actually owner and chief
at trilla
whatever that means and you're sure that
he's the one that made this
no he shared it
okay he shared it so show me where he
shared i just want to show the paper
trill
it was so here's this guy bobby sean
he has trailer trailer fight club all
this [ __ ] okay so he's obviously
associated
yeah and then
this is insane wait this this is this is
insane so just bear with us as we
establish the facts of this here
here is he is an accountant trailer
apparently
yeah he's must be crushing it 400 views
yep trailers off the rails bro
let's watch one of his 400 views
oh i can't listen he's got music
nope okay so
here he is okay hang on
so
here he is this is triller oh my god
it is real
yeah
wait till you see this i [ __ ]
flabbergasted
this is triller's main twitter account
so unless they were hacked or something
you know
which seems unlikely because they
here's a scripture of him sharing it on
his story as well
wait they did they tagged the nft
artists what is that who did they tag
here
oh
excuse me i just coughed right into that
[ __ ] mic
did he come because like who did he
attack here is he's the artist i just
want to make sure we get it straight
before i make any
statement here yeah i guess that's what
they're so it's possible that they did
work with the artist on this
no they work with some artists yeah i
guess yeah
well what it is so we know it's official
so why don't you explain it love
yeah so
on this website there's a bunch of
famous nfts
that's on the normal blockchain
made by real artists but when we go on
this website
the owner or the creator says that it's
thriller who created them so it's either
a bad website design
or they're claiming they made something
that they
didn't make if that makes sense huh
can you well there's like really famous
ones like
i don't how the [ __ ] do i look okay here
this one buy now for 1.5 million
good deal
but can you not see it on the blockchain
you can see if it's owned or who it's
created by right
yeah i can check that now sorry i wasn't
prepared to do this oh it's in my
document i thought you were that's okay
i had no clue
so um
this is a famous nft right
it's one of these stupid for support
board apes
is anyone in the market for a 1.5
million dollar
um
[ __ ]
dumbass it's not doesn't even look good
it looks
bad it looks stupid
i tend to agree with you
okay whatever maybe we're not ready to
talk about this yeah i i don't even
understand what we're doing
so far
so it's triller nfts.com
well apparently yo
real quick
this is big news
i actually that one that 1.5 million
dollar nft i just copped it
got it for free let's put it back on the
blockchain [ __ ] yeah dude let's put it
back up for one i'm rich [ __ ] i
just [ __ ] lifted this right off of
their website
use your gamer chair hack right yeah
that's right i guess something something
we could talk about that's kind of funny
even though we have no information on it
i i did find this uh archived website if
i i went back a couple months
and i found this archive if you show it
on the screen
yeah it's on the screen a
trailer nft for 10 million usd by now
price and it seems to be the
fight
i'm not mistaken
got us in trouble no it's another fight
oh it's that's the earlier one with jake
paul bid now tomorrow the one-of-a-kind
nft of jake paul's unforgettable
knockout punch of nate robinson
stop it one of the most talked about and
controversial sport and cultural events
of 2020
offer also includes the first ever nft
future
offered to public winning bidder will
also own the last 30 seconds
of the upcoming jake paul vs ben askren
fight
headlining the april 17th trailer this
is so stupid buy now buy now
10 million dollars current bid 2 600.
wait did so did someone actually win
this
somebody bid
2600 for it evidently
they got a bargain on that buy now
does that mean they own the fight that
they're suing for
the person who got this nft no it
doesn't
sadly nfts don't transfer ownership or
anything
that's unfortunate you know somebody's
already offering me 420 fupa coins for
the [ __ ] nft
you're gonna have to go higher than that
i did i own a [ __ ] ton of cooper coin
man yeah yeah yeah that's right you were
an early investor
i think it skyrocketed or maybe it went
down i don't know i haven't checked okay
whatever sorry that was a tangent
whatever
maybe you guys can give more intel on
this drill or nft
it be they look like the exact same but
if i don't know if they collaborated
with the artist or not or what's going
on here but these are like famous nfts
yeah i'll look into that for next that
were reposted to their website
i mean maybe they bought the stupid
monkey and then they're just reselling
it well on open c the monkey is at like
over 250 k and then on triller it's a
different name and a different amount
this is by now four for one point five
yeah
okay what's this one look this one up
the pirate baby cyberkong2748
that seems like so specific
do they own this or
what is chat saying is there anyone
they're mostly just bidding on my nft
[ __ ] everyone just wants to buy yeah all
right we're up to 480 keep that going
people
get that up okay hold on now hold on
i'm gonna [ __ ] i [ __ ] own this [ __ ]
now boy
look
this is mine
is my [ __ ] now [ __ ]
i found the id for the original this is
mine [ __ ]
you gonna get sued for that
and i was playing
go ahead love
so the first idea i sent in shot there
yeah
is for the one on the trailer trilogy
website yeah and the other one is for
the official one it is they're
definitely so they have different ids
which is the whole point of the nfd
that's whole point yeah it's just so
confused
so this is for short different things on
the blockchain
wow that was fast
cam you cooked that up quick boy
just use that as my shop dan has turned
into a board ape yep
just any time i'm talking you can just
cut to that okay so as far as our
understanding goes based on our
bit of research it has a different
blockchain id than the real one
[Music]
now what the [ __ ] is going on here
have you been able to find triller's nft
wallet
it should be easy to find right
yeah here's the collection id like
what's there
by the way if you guys want to bid on my
uh pirate baby
i'm opening the fupa coin hold on hold
on
you're kind of you're steam rolling my i
got an open uh auction going on right
now this is my fupa baby i'm changing
the name
and you can bid starting bid is at a
hundred thousand football coins
going to the moon baby
actually i only take safe moon i need 10
trillion safe for this
i need a i need a quadrillion uh
anyway let's move on what the [ __ ] i'm
not going anywhere with this
but it's just it's weird
it's just weird that's awesome
yeah and then this was another cav cav
one eel i don't know if you saw this
this [ __ ] guy he doesn't know that we
can see everything he's doing
he started running an ad
oh did it stop there's actually if he's
no it's loading there's multiple ads oh
so he made more because before there was
just one yeah so he's this guy's [ __ ]
dumb he's running a tech company he
doesn't understand he has boomer
understanding of everything so we can
see his ads
you know what it is you got to turn off
adblock okay
he has boomer understanding of the of
the
[ __ ]
thank you yeah
i just want to turn it off on this page
so
we someone's posted that he was oh yeah
so he's got a bunch down oh this is
[ __ ] awesome
this is awesome so you can see his paid
ads yeah it's it's part of their
transparency
after the election
yeah so somebody got an ad for this
well you can see the ad here if i zoom
in yeah
it's the his article and then me being
accused of racism and homophobia
so he's running ads
to assassinate my character
and it says for people who just blindly
believe what ethan is preaching he's
lying and by doing his bidding you are
helping him harm a lot of people
while putting millions in his pocket a
lot of people who are we harming
a lot of people
apparently i'm making a lot of money
from
i wish i that were true
i'm just making fun of you for free my
friend
unfortunately do it all day for free in
fact it's costing me a shitload of money
to goof on you dude yeah way more if you
scroll down his variety article is on
there um the one that he's trying to
share the one that he edited
showman of the year allegedly oh [ __ ]
he's promoting this cringe
go
an article from 10 years ago
with the date edited out my
guess is that he wants when people look
up ryan cavanaugh variety this is what
they find
slick
let's see if that works
ryan
kavanagh
variety
uh no ponzi scheme
still up
let me do it i wonder if they'll ever
take that down
well that's between him and them right
yeah
i mean i cashed it
yeah of course
yeah of course ryan kavanaugh variety
this is uh incognito yeah it's the ponzi
scheme one still
the article of you know what i'm saying
not saying he did a ponzi
there's a lot of variety articles about
him that look not very
soon adam fields over fake harassment
paid him oh this is a new one right
kavanaugh
paid himself 2.6 million as company
struggled damn that sounds scummy right
sounds like you're trying to okay i'll
just take a damn bro
it's like everything that comes up is
bad
crazy huh
um anyway
i love that so yeah he's promoting this
is so [ __ ] awesome you guys
isn't this great
oh my god
what's on the screen creeping me
that's right save the kid coins
so what else couldn't be more okay so
he's saying he's proud of his dad why
are you promoting that oh so this
actually gives some interesting insight
into where his wealth comes from could
it be more proud of jack kavanaugh aka
dad
always changing the world first he
bought the word
first he brought the word
what the [ __ ] you say brought the world
is what he's trying to say but there's a
time he promoted
with the typo
he's probably drunk when he wrote it
i don't know how we could know that of
course i said probably okay yeah
i mean i know he i would it's safe to
assume he likes drinking he might have
been wet and wild yeah
maybe
first he brought the world the most
important breakthrough in cancer in our
lifetime
and now nanotech wow his dad sounds
pretty cool what happened
well from what i understand his dad is
either the owner or investor in a ton of
uh like pharmaceutical company type
stuff and like medical research stuff
yeah his dad is is actually
from i haven't done a deep dive in on
anything but i was curious because of
the story about him becoming a venture
capitalist right out of college i was
like okay well obviously you're a trust
fund baby so where did that money come
from and yeah his uh father so daddy's
been funding him
well with that at least when he got
started that explains to me how like he
goes from bankrupting relativity being
an abject failure
lampooned by the industry
to being like okay now i'm buying
triller
it's like where'd that money come from
yeah
okay interesting golden parachute
he's promoting a post about his dad
i found
an epic article of kind of afraid
let's let's check it out there well whoa
whoa no no no more of this live looking
into this stuff this is not good send it
to me and the discord let me browse the
title let them look into it first let's
let me look at the title
oh wow holy [ __ ]
wait i can't read the title
here let's read the whole article
that way
nobody can complain
let me scroll to the bottom and see if
there's any corrections that's what i
was looking for
same thing i don't see any corrections
this is so interesting
wow roll it so if you look at because
his dad is jack kavanagh
correct
wow so this is [ __ ] fascinating
relativity media's ceo's father will pay
damages for selling a fake picasso
daddy chill runs in the family
so these things are accidents sometimes
that's true that's true he may you know
he may have not known it well let's read
the article los angeles jury on friday
found that jack cavanaugh fathered
relativity of ceo ryan kevin defrauded
his former friend victor sands in the
sale of a phony picasso and awarded
sends close to 3.5 million damages
jack kavanagh was ordered to pay stands
250 and punitive damage and the jury
awarded him an additional 3.2 and
compensatory damages damn
sounds pretty serious
sans filed suit against the elder kevin
on december 2010 claiming kavanaugh
persuaded sans to invest more than 6
million
in a series of dubious ventures from
which kavanaugh stood to personally
benefit oh
the most significant of these cases and
the sexiest involved the work of our
purported to be by pablo picasso sans
who paid two million for the fourth
interjection and the second yeah in the
sixth yeah
okay
number one
sans who paid 2 million for the for the
forged piece accused kavanaugh of
receiving 800 thousand dollars from l.a
of calorie owner tatia khan for
arranging the deal sans also accused of
kavanaugh's wife leslie
whoa another defendant in the case was
being complicit in the deception wow
in 2010 khan agreed to plead guilty to
federal fraud charges
as part of her plea deal she agreed to
pay restitution for the fake picasso
canada's lawyer eric george believes
that 2.2 million of the 3.2 million has
already been accounted for
through the payments made by khan we've
always maintained as the fbi concluded
fbi were involved in this juicy little
[ __ ] tidbit
so the kavanaugh family has some
experience dealing with federal federal
agents
i have no way of knowing keep reading
the rest of this paragraph though
because this does seem relevant
we're all we've always maintained as the
fbi concluded that no one bears
responsibility other than the woman who
was
uh convicted by the u.s attorney for
commissioning the forgery okay right
yeah in any event the jury special
verdict confirms that the plaintiff
suffered
no damages other than legal fees and
costs he neither pleaded nor is illegal
entitled to but that's real interesting
because
it sounds like
the jury based on the information they
saw
it sounds like kavanaugh made 800 000
but was awarded way more than that 3.2
plus 250.
um
sam's lawyer
i don't care about sand we've been very
grateful that the jury saw the action of
jack and leslie kavanaugh for what they
were which was a successful attempt to
defraud my client
when the verdict was delivered the jury
was asked do you find any clear and
convincing evidence that jack kavanaugh
engaged in conduct that is malicious
oppressive or fraudulent the jury
replied yes
also finding kavanaugh guilty of breach
of fiduciary duties
intentional misrepresentation negligent
misrepresentation and concealment among
other charges
convicted i mean that's pretty good
right from the jury that's pretty
serious that sounds very serious
still george argued that because other
claims had been dismissed
his client would be entitled to recoup
attorney fees
uh we're gratified we prevailed on the
majority of the claims and
and they were dismissed as we're
entitled to do we will proceed in the
next phase of the trial to discover all
of our attorneys fees and related to
those dismissal claims
apparently this was a really big deal in
the art world i see this story showing i
feel like i've seen a documentary about
this history of the most notorious art
scandals and scams in history and this
is one of them that's listed
yeah i saw something kind of recently
about
basically
stuff like this like like they were
selling fake
artworks in the millions
you know eight million crazy stuff
okay well
this is insane because it we can
basically say
that if you go down the jury
found
jack kavanaugh ryan cavanaugh's father
guilt or they said they found him to be
uh engaging in malicious oppressive and
fraudulent conduct
crazy huh
that is really crazy i have no way of
knowing but
maybe the picasso was flipped it was
upside down why wouldn't they just do it
why don't they just oh right yeah i mean
yeah hell yeah
yeah so that's real interesting though
when you learn
that a jury found that about his dad it
kind of inform
tells you a little bit about maybe the
conduct of
his his
family his children
not me i'm not i'm only quoting the
what the jury said so
there you go
this is good [ __ ] though don't you guys
think
it's really interesting
i actually got to look into that because
that case sounds like super [ __ ]
interesting eh
i want to learn more about this jack
kavanagh character
you see anything else on him
he sounds like an interesting guy
everyone said shout out abe for the
fifth lawsuit we got you
maybe just move on no no no no
[Laughter]
his linkedin's not that interesting is
he damn he looks like trump what the
[ __ ]
oh no he doesn't
all right i'm not gonna look at his
linkedin i mean
too far too far
we got so much juice
today a lot of other things to talk
about what do we got an entire episode
on ryan kavanagh family family family
family family
family family family family stop
um
you guys were a little off
yeah that was not a good one
the picasso in question
there was a small towel it was a
actually a board ape
i don't think we've also
painted any board apes
oh maybe he did
maybe that's why it's so valuable
i'm trying to think what was the name of
the documentary that i watched because
it was really interesting
is it made you look does anybody know
that sounds familiar potentially i swear
i learned about this exact thing and
that lady she was like a prolific she
worked with like a chinese artist
exactly who was like this prolific
forger yeah
and he was like the best forger ever
but but they were part of like a legit
gallery thank you dude and basically
that whole gallery went
yeah
this guy this chinese artist he was like
the most prolific forger nobody could
figure out the only way they figured out
these were actually fake was by doing
like these really deep
research on the uh prominent
providence prominence what is the word
the history of the pieces you know like
they were unaccounted for in the history
books
right they're like how do they keep
coming up with
um i'm not seeing any reference to this
con character in the
uh description of the documentary so
it's possible it was a different uh
different scandal
but i'm still
trying to see if there's any connection
there
yeah by the way this one that they're
bragging they won
it was about some random youtube channel
that didn't respond
to the uh
to the judgment or to the
this
i'm not super familiar but i think it
was just a fail to answer
so they've got a big dub on that one
all right that's it
thank you
oh now let's talk about keemstar okay
everyone loves that
oh no no no there's one more thing i
gotta watch
this [ __ ] guy he had a fight the
other night you got to see what this
guy's wearing dude
what the [ __ ] is this
invitation on your instagram is he here
i've been looking for him i did invite
him on my instagram um and there's the
invite
um
i i did
ask him if he wanted to come
to learn how a proper production is done
because you know dana's idea of a proper
production is throw up a little rusty
ring you know pay his fighters what we
pay our ushers
uh you know
throw one little fight have a guy knock
a guy out and call it a night i this is
what a production is thanks to our
wonderful production team and i thought
dana might want to come and learn a
thing or two here but you know he can
keep underpaid his fighters and taking
home his own money and throwing up that
rusty little ring wow talking like a
you man nick cannon will do anything
yeah i know nick cannon what the [ __ ]
was that
and he should hit him with a lawsuit he
should hit him with the lawsuit
by the way maybe he should have
rehearsed that a couple times my dude
what the [ __ ] is this shirt what's
happening here you guys
you're not supposed to wear white
underweight most people don't know that
but it shows up wait what's happening in
the sleeve that's exactly like are we
even sure that this isn't one piece of
clothing
i don't know what's worse
i think he's wearing like a really loose
long sleeve white shirt and then like a
tighter white t-shirt
dude
you put up an amazing invitation on your
instagram is he here
i've been looking wow i wonder if i've
been looking for him but he's uh home
with his money his own money not giving
the money to the
fighters but
actually what we do is we steal the ip
of other companies
i got harry potter i got hairy legs
i might want to come and learn a thing
or two here yeah and kate just because
there's controversy over with ryan
they're being sued for use for
allegedly stealing someone's ip in the
triangle ring which exactly but you know
he can keep underpaid his fighters and
taking home his own money and throwing
up that rusty little ring so turn
you're not fooling anyone like
we all know they're the
we all know you're a baby compared to
them
so if anyone wants to watch it is made
you look that's what it's called oh made
you look is it about true crime style
documentary which investigates how an
older
gallery an esteemed 165 year old
institution in new york city
sold nearly 80 million worth of forged
jackson pollock marx rothko mark rothko
and others so i don't know if it's about
the same thing but it doesn't sound like
it it sounds like a very similar kind of
operation really interesting though yeah
yes so this this crit this chinese guy
was able to emulate people's art style
exactly
so he would make he wouldn't he wasn't
even copying [ __ ] he was making new art
they looked exactly like theirs and they
were just oh so you were just dying yeah
and they're saying oh no
we found this this is a long lost one
a long lost slime and they would send it
to like historians and chronologers and
biographers and they would all say it
looks real wow
that's i mean that's impressive in its
own right like i mean obviously it's
dishonest but like being able to you
know the guy emulates the style the guy
was a prodigy himself yes yeah the
people who were dealing with families
and um
the only way they were able to like
figure it out they would analyze the ink
and they would see that like the ink
wasn't old like they're cracked in
certain ways like the old ink that
sounds really fascinating yeah that's
good just made you look that up made you
look
all right that's it
all right so now we move on to keemstar
is he in the thumbnail no
nah
you know snitch on me
he had a thumbnail for a new drama alert
that would [ __ ] crack me up show me
that [ __ ]
could someone grab me a saudi needle
i need a pick-me-up you want anything
new
sorry too can we get some sodies in the
house
bow
it's red okay
do you guys have eyes
here you guys can put some ice in the
cup thank you look at this thumbnail
lena instacart this is bad
this bad it's like a caveman this
or this is what he thinks of his
audience
a book huh
this video is [ __ ]
murder animals
this bad
like what is this
it's bad
this bird i [ __ ] up
a book huh
and a buck
this bird
huh
all right so what's real interesting
dude so cute the dogs what
the calzones giving me heartburn it was
[ __ ] gnarly bruh yeah i feel okay
though like it was delicious but i just
had last night my first uh heartburn
for this pregnancy
oh right that's like a thing when you're
pregnant it gets really bad last time it
happened to me at the end too
so
yeah maybe these are i'm having sympathy
pains for you right now my body is uh
definitely not handling it as easily as
the first time huh
huh
you know what's funny is eli describe
some of this stuff but it's some weird
things happening
you can say it i mean you can be open
about it i think it's interesting
we like radical honesty here on the show
you say it you want me to say it i won't
say it i can say it you can say it if
you say it okay so ela's
uh
you see
vaginal area has been
uh
swollen yeah
that's it
that's it's pretty normal right
and she had to ice her [ __ ]
that's you gotta sit on ice
oh my goodness stop it that's disgusting
stop it william
do you ice it or did you not did you
stop
stop because i wasn't sure i was doing
anything it's probably really
uncomfortable
so is there any treatment for it
no are you just like bulging out
so
in pregnancy
you have like more blood i guess or
your blood is
creating more or whatever it is and uh
so swelling happens in general
and then
i don't know my theory is maybe
because i'm sitting a lot more lately
right right i've been sitting more and
like doing work on the computer and
stuff so maybe because of that
you could be sure some people
um will have their feet
you know their feet
happen did it happen to you where your
feet swell
i think they're a little bit but not
crazy
yeah so
what's interesting thank you so much
olivia
not to not shatter calm down shredder
it's okay a few people saying there's
icy underwear for pregnant i see
underwear yeah and somebody's wearing
frozen pads yo we gotta get you some
frozen panties bro
you want do you want some frozen undies
i'll try it
where do i buy that
macy's
the frozen section at ralph's
there you go
padsicles
[Laughter]
that's cool
doesn't a padsicle imply that you're
supposed to eat it
uh
well
i guess not they give you step-by-step
instructions to make them yourself so
there you go oh my god we're not you
want to make do we oh you make them
yourself i guess so i guess i mean you
just put in the freezer
lay a piece of aluminum foil on the
counter top
make sure you have enough to wipe around
a
sanitary napkin
what is a sanitary napkin is that just
another term for a pad
oh probably why they call it
wrap a sanitary napkin or pad and lay it
on the foil
remove adhesive paper tabs
squeeze unscented pure aloe vera gel
generously
spread it around
pour spray alcohol free witch hazel over
the pad i'm not putting witch hazel on
your [ __ ]
genitals no no it doesn't wanted to
lavender essential oil blah blah blah
and then i imagine you pop it in the
freezer
just
all right all right
anyway we'll we'll work on the popsicle
the potsicle
but anyway you know what's funny is not
to diminish your discomfort that you're
going through
but
i feel like a lot of the stuff you
experience is what i experience on an
everyday basis just from being fat
well yeah like i got heartburn i was
like oh really and then you're like i
can't get up i'm too fat but obviously i
do this for myself i gotta say if you're
looking at the chat
a lot of
our uh
fans that our mothers have uh are
swearing by this saying that it's that
it's great and the witch hazel is good
i'll i'll make you i'll make you a pad
sickle tonight what is a witch hazel
i think that's just like a herb you know
like aloe vera or something i don't i
think we can skip the witch hazel no
they're saying that they're saying the
witch hazel is the witch hazel is the
good [ __ ] it's the stuff they use in
preparation age someone said okay so
witch hazel is normal normal not like
steroids on the face okay
called out why they gotta name it witch
hazel they want me to use it well that's
probably the plant that it comes from
but it you know like how aloe vera is a
plant yeah oh yeah well my favorite
plant's like nazi holocaust
like why you gotta call it witch hazel
makes it sound like they're casting an
evil spell on you
uh i love the nazi tulip well early
puritan settlers in new england adopted
witch hazel as disposed of remedy from
the natives and why they established the
united states in the 19th century maybe
like magic it works like magic
yeah well my favorite flower is the um
trail of tears or rose
it helps with uh but it helps with the
athlete's foot
[Laughter]
we'll put some trailer tears tulip juice
under
oh my god that's the call elo
yo
going back to the keem thing real quick
dropping the hottest album
[Laughter]
[Music]
this
bad
all right let's talk about keemstar you
know this shit's all good you guys know
it's gonna be good
i love witches if there's witches in the
chats please don't hex me
don't next me witches
i've been cursed by a witch once already
remember that
we made that one reaction video to the
male the uh the witch yeah and i was
like please don't hex me bro and she did
it was a guy actually he did he says he
didn't but i think he did
[ __ ] around and found out
i [ __ ] up
all right so here's my here's where it
gets real interesting i was reading over
the complaint
wait we were moving on no we're moving
on to keemstar oh
no
and you know obviously this is good this
is good
so there's in this complaint for some
[ __ ] reason you guys
keemstar is brought up yeah
all over this complaint
that's unbelievable why is
keemstar story being told in this
lawsuit against me
i've long suspected that keemstar and
ryan kavanagh actually you've seen
because peop people reached out to ryan
in the dm's just goofing around and
they're like yo i got dirt on ethan and
he's like yo let me see it so it would
be really easy for keemstar to reach out
to ryan and be like yo i got a dossier
on ethan and ryan be like let's meet up
for some [ __ ] modding yeah i i
already think he does that with anyone
that we have any slight
um beef with
for sure i think he already does that so
that's probably what happened here
but i just think it's funny i think it's
really worth talking about in that you
you look at all these commentary
channels that like
hate me and like
make every exception in the world for
keemstar weird
i mean those people are branded
well keemstar is supporting a guy who's
trying let me read this i've long
suspected keemstar working with ryan
cavanaugh to get my channel banned to
weaken fair use and stifle free speech
and this being included in the lawsuit's
pretty compelling evidence support that
why would they include this look at this
klein's content is deliberately
offensive provocative and inflammatory
frequently he mocks and harasses other
social media personalities to attract
attention
and entertain
viewers
none of that's illegal weird
well i appreciate that they say i'm
enter entertain at least because that's
like okay good yeah
also just your opinion bro
for example in august of 2021 youtube
suspended klein for seven days for
violating his harassment policy by
posting content
that
degradingly sexualized where did they
get that quote from
his 20 year old girlfriend yeah why is
that in quotes
yeah i wonder
what are you doing
what's your source keemstar yeah exactly
attribution for kimi there
uh his 20 year old girlfriend
well the only one getting degraded uh
the only person degrading that 20 year
old was keemstar
uh
showing pictures of her to face banks
and talking about what a piece of ash
she was
right
i forgot about it
yeah that was like oh my god i totally
forgot like a romeo juliet
yikes
so um the 20 year old girlfriend of
another youtube content creator daniel
keem this occurred during an episode of
h3 after dark in which kline had someone
call into the show pretending to be
keem's girlfriend who said that keem
well
i'm just reading from a legal profile
i'm not doing anything who said that kim
cries during sex and has a small genital
genitalia
following how did this make it into the
law it has no [ __ ] relevance none
i mean i guess they're just trying to
paint me to be like a bad guy but you
gotta love this this is like the best
characterization of all time i'm a bad
guy and keemstar this poor defenseless
vlad
by the way i called into a yeah every
radio show in the world does that we had
a [ __ ] parody of keemstar okay
whatever yeah fallen client suspension
king posted video stating justice has
been served and he deserved it it's well
overdue the stuff that is said on that
podcast to bully and harass other
creators would never fly on anyone
else's channel that show has been
harassing so many [ __ ] creators
so many [ __ ] youtubers so keemstar is
able to do his grands his righteous
grandstanding and ryan kavanagh's
lawsuit
what the [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
it's like psychotic bro yeah why don't
you bring in this this is a great one
why don't you bring in trisha and matt
hoss for a quote too while you're at it
okay [ __ ] wait they did
not in my house
oh yeah they did bring up trish yeah
trisha is in this lawsuit as well they
mentioned treachery in frenemies i was
like what the [ __ ]
this is crazy
oh wild ride man everything is so like
out of context too of course yeah
yeah i mean emily when in her stream she
seemed to indicate that this is not
uncommon because you know obviously it's
their complaints so they're going to
like try and characterize it as much as
they can but i i do find it
like
i guess it just depends on the judge and
their kind of disposition towards this
kind of stuff because the fact of the
matter like it's totally irrelevant it's
so [ __ ] irrelevant to the question at
hand which is defamation and a very
specific instance of defamation like
what you do else like on our show
otherwise well there's no [ __ ]
bearing on what
the core of the lawsuit is at all it's
like
well one possibility is like in a
lawsuit you have certain rights to say
whatever the [ __ ] you want and so
they can use this right and they can
exploit this right to basically air
whatever dirty laundry they think i have
in a public pocket yeah it just seems so
it's just apparently like trying to kind
of like like hey this guy's a piece of
[ __ ] so you should you know yeah it's
just gonna upset the judge
yeah exactly that's what i meant by the
disposition of the judge because i feel
like some people would look at this and
be like what is this like who cares how
is the judge even gonna make sense of
this
right like this like weird youtube beef
yeah and that's another reason that i
think it's from keem because who else
would make this argument besides him
because yeah everyone else who knows
youtube will be like oh well keem said
this about ethan's wife he said he's
going to steal his son's child uh
college fund i'm sorry yeah it's so
easy to lied about me you won't talk
about real defamation he actually did
really actually information yeah but
guess what lucky keemstar is i don't sue
people i only get very lucky for
keemstar i don't get i don't sue people
you need to go down for that fun [ __ ] i
get sued actually all the [ __ ] time i
love how emily she goes ethan who's
somehow a lightning rod for lawsuits
like not me i don't sue anyone i never
sued anyone in my whole damn life and i
don't plan to ever
i'm not literally going to take the
teddy brush away
yeah oh maybe wants to take a walk
shred you are so sweet what the hell
[Music]
shredder's so sweet
such a sweet soul you know what i love
about shredder is that like he doesn't
[ __ ] with anyone but me and you
he doesn't have time for anybody but me
or you
you just won't be touched guitars won't
be near he doesn't have anything to do
with you
but to me and you he's like the sweetest
most loving dog in the world
and everyone else he [ __ ]
jumps at him and scares him
barks at him
i didn't know dogs could push he pushed
me
yeah he does that he does that
he gets us at the back of the knee he
does it to us and then you're like
[Music]
how do you describe him well he can get
you right yeah right in the back of the
knee yeah
he gives you a dead leg even though
yeah even though he weighs like six
pounds he can buckle your ass sweeter
than your parents dog i'll say that
boss is the [ __ ] worst trying to kill
amy my parents dog i love every dog and
i hate my parents dog
poor wallace well not really poor
wallace he's fine he's a sweet dog but i
don't know
he's like he's a deceptively big massive
dog
and you know he's also a rescue
and
sometimes for no apparent reason we'll
all be chilling and he'll just
lunge and bark and
scare the [ __ ] and he's got the deepest
bark yeah he's scariest
do you do you let him around theodore or
no yeah yeah he's okay actually with
kids
with our family immediate family he's
never done that
it's just people here we have friends
over or
a b over
or
going after you right ian
yeah yeah no way you don't remember that
i remember i don't remember got me on
the ankle and got me pretty good holy
[ __ ] he bit me a month ago yeah i keep
telling your parents we're going to get
another lawsuit because of what
i say listen your dog is dangerous and
my parents they're so [ __ ]
they're just they don't she's like
okay
yeah
they bring the dog to my house where we
have workers and stuff and they let them
off the leash and then people are like
every time i saw him he wanted to cujo
me so bad i could see it
yeah
also he plays way too rough with alfredo
i know
[Music]
and then i go mom and dad get take care
of your [ __ ] dog he's trying to kill
my dog
oh they're just playing no they're just
playing what the [ __ ] alfredo's on his
back like fighting for his life
[Music]
yeah but when alfredo turns in al frico
he'll [ __ ] him up yeah frick oh is scary
actually funnily when shredder don't
take [ __ ] from wallace mm-hmm shredder's
the only dog that put walls in his place
i felt bad i don't want to tell your
parents because they're so sweet but
then your dad's like oh i'm just gonna
let him out for a little bit i'm like oh
yeah he bit me like two minutes ago
did you say that yeah i told your
yeah he felt bad he kept apologizing i
was like no it's fine he just did he
still let him off the leash no he didn't
yeah he should but the point is he
should know better well
he should you shouldn't have to even he
shouldn't have to have bit had to bite
you before i don't know if he knew i was
there because
me and theodore were doing the
decorations with lena
that's true yeah
psycho dog scooby dooby doo
anyway he says um to this day klein
routinely complains about keem at length
during his podcast yeah i wonder why
having received the suspension from
youtube for his attacks on game early
this year
um who wrote this keemstar ryan
cavanaugh
so weird
but anyway now basically we can say
that keemstar
according to this court filing
this small genitalia is now canon
it's a matter of public public record
yeah public interest
that is [ __ ] amazing so funny
um
let's see
hopefully it doesn't go to discovery
oh
by the way
yeah i'm going to need a picture to know
if i defend you or not
because if you well anyway let's not
joke about that it's serious we don't
want to we don't want to make any
uncomfortable jokes
just reading the court filing which is
my legal right
absolutely
absolutely and they're the ones that
wrote it in there
huh
um
yeah but if we do get far enough to
where we depose ryan i'm definitely
gonna ask him have you been in contact
with
daniel came and he's under oath so he's
not going to lie
although he has lied under oath before
wait
ryan kavanaugh
when
um when he was the
judge went during the sexual the fake
sexual men memo thing
yeah that's true that's true yeah okay
take your word for it
yeah so one of the first fourth lawsuit
yeah no it's true yeah he did i mean it
was reported
i mean it's true that it was reported
okay
let's say that
maybe's confirming it
just pull up the source just be careful
just be careful with us kind of things
but
the first thing i would ask ryan
if i were to depose him is have you ever
lied under oath
because it's like you're he's taking an
oath not to lie
right and it's like well if you've
already lied under oath how can we trust
anything you say right
it's pretty good
got him it's pretty good
maybe you've got something for me
it's all brett kavanaugh lying under
oath yeah
oh brett kavanaugh nope not about that
i like beer do you like drink beer
and having some beers with friends
well i think i can assume ryan likes
beer too right
so they have that maybe once upon a time
yeah
well here this was around 2007.
hold on
ryan kavanagh just type his name
i believe it's in doubt yeah here
here
so this is the one about fabricating uh
sh
um here let me control f oath
in particular he declared under oath
an attempt to explain why the memorandum
has not been produced earlier relativity
subjected
submitted false declarations from mr
kavanaugh
mr kavanaugh claimed in his declaration
that he was the one
to ferret out the location of the
memorandum in particular he declared
under oath that he suspected the
document had not been produced because
it was in a private folder oh yeah that
seems pretty definitive yeah the the
judge is the one who said hey yeah
ladies and gentlemen thank you dan we
got him
he had found it out of a private folder
um
regarding miss genus who was no longer
an employer relativity right that's the
person that
they tried to pin
miss geniuses supposed private folder he
he uh fortuitously located the memo and
provided it to council
all right well deadline says so
yeah we found that we actually sourced
that from our very own website
right love
yes that's correct like if you go if you
type ryan kavanagh and go down to i see
that article is linked does rank cabinet
look like harvey weinstein
we actually source
our claims here for example this one
says lying under oath
if you refresh the page real quick
it's sourced
so if you go
it's not given oh there it is oh it's
not a clickable link oh it's not link oh
[ __ ]
it's a work in progress guys
so yeah uh
lying under oath
[ __ ] out right
can i just say i i got to say something
real quick
people in the chat that are spamming
move on
if this this is what's going on in our
lives right now okay it's it's going to
be talked about he's going to come here
and hit me up with the lead you move on
you're the one that needs to move on
move on
who's going to hit me with the move on
when i'm talking about
i have to say literally don't try to
move on in any context because that
quote is actually time out like
automatically timed out for once oh
that's epic well there you go get the
[ __ ] out
are people really leaving move on
yeah but
it's not a lot of people but yeah and it
automatically gets deleted because it's
in the auto mod but honestly don't like
don't move it's just
just oh so don't write don't move on oh
because that phrase will still get you
well people that were doing that we
appreciate
i'm sorry you got caught in the drag mat
there oh you're trying to just getting
browned
no i won't get anybody no
wonderfully honestly are you done
family family family family family
family
[Music]
oh really
there's another keems there's keemstar
mentions all throughout this
it's so interesting that's just so funny
um
yeah here you can see
um
something about small genitals in 2020
daniel king posted a video suggesting
klein was lying about using his own
funds to pay his legal fees in an
ongoing copyright lawsuit and response
client produced a video about keem
titled content are you gonna mention
this this is like this is when the
keemstar actually defamed us yes yeah
how are you gonna also i won that
lawsuit right
everything about this how are they even
gonna make it isn't it mind bending
crazy they say according to may 2020
business insider article clients fans
sent numerous messages and comments to
social media accounts associated with
the energy drink g fuel urging the brand
to cancel its partnership of keem and
the since removed video posted by keem
he claimed it's since been removed
that's crazy because the variety article
is still up
and they're voting for something that
was removed he claimed that klein was
setting a dangerous precedent for the
commentary community
by encouraging his followers to spam
keem's sponsors
and reportedly threaten to sue klein
over his lost sponsorship yeah how has
that gone for him anything else you want
to tell us about keem like maybe a
little biographic
like why
that video who cares about what kim has
to say and what video well and by the
way when you write a complaint you don't
have infinite space you have a finite
box to work in and they've spent like
three whole pages talking about keemstar
it's just suspicious it's odd it's
[ __ ] weird
of anybody what's going on
what is going on what's going on a book
huh
what what yeah i think in the in the
next lawsuit they're going to be quoting
from beau blacks bobby
i'll just
gather all of his uh
content and transcribe it i would love
to hear bublex read the lawsuit actually
that'd be pretty
i mean it is i mean why not right
by the way i thought i saw keemstar
retweeting this i thought it was so
funny
apparently after my tweets about him
keemstar retiring at his pink
and h3 fighting a lull suit wait zoom in
on the kingstown picture this is a man
he's a man
bottom
rock bottom you may not like it but this
is peak male performance right
yeah okay
red flag he's wearing a versace robe by
himself
in his house
in his house by himself red flag number
four
[Music]
this is peak performance crying he's got
an evil beard
that's like out of the movies died and
lined up allegedly for sure though
[Music]
i don't think he's going to sue you over
saying his beard has died i would love
if he did and we had to test it
actually said it himself oh that he does
diet okay
yeah so frustrated but you got to love
this he really thinks he's at his peak
here i mean
me
also can we talk about the fact that
he's saying it about himself
well he retweeted he originated but he's
well yeah same
yo this is
this is bad
someone said keemstar is going through a
midlife crisis and hits on girls who
have just graduated high school ethan's
building a family with a loving
successful wife i mean the only thing i
mean yeah i'm massive here and you know
well also look at the picture you're not
even trying yeah i was making a joke
yeah
but dude you're like almost 40 i mean
this is not
keemstar shut
up if gibson thinks this is peak then
what is the bottom of the yeah
apparently having a loving family oh
there you go all right then he flipped i
think he was saying he peaked in high
school is what he was trying to say i
could see that i'm always running around
getting i just dyed the beard and
they're still gray okay so there you
have it
is that ian oh
sorry ian i swear i thought it was ian
doesn't look like him
no
sorry
sorry sorry sorry i don't know why
i thought that
um
there was also a clip oh he posted this
today ela you'll get a kick out of this
totally by the way this is a man in his
peak
everything is going all good in
keemstar's life clearly
what's happening with his retirement
yeah he's trying to find someone but
every everyone he's friends with is like
a degenerate [ __ ]
loser he said he'd retire on his
birthday in march
just retire bruh and then my guests come
back don't wait on april 1st april fools
well anyway
this is a man in his peak
dear god
i mean what is this bandana this is a
new look now
he's been doing that for a bit now wait
because like people keep telling him to
take off the hat so crap yeah it's like
that hulk hogan although that dude is so
[ __ ] bald he's got to cover his
forehead
i mean the only other person that wears
this is the bad guy from tiger king
what's his name joe
and jeff jeff lowe oh yeah
like joe is a good guy jeff lowe
joe exotic is free joe exotic bro
kimster would totally hang out with jeff
lowe
all their best friends did anyone watch
the new tiger king yet yeah yeah i
watched it can we talk about it
i thought it was good it was good and it
made it made joe seem maybe like
they did him dirty yeah i mean they
definitely [ __ ] them over without a
doubt anyway just watch this this is a
man in his peak you uh this is an
important video dear god
let me turn on the music so i can
so i can pray
dear heavenly father
creator of
worlds i ask this of you
please send meteors from outer space
to crash into the homes and kill
all of my enemies all the people that
lie about me online that make [ __ ]
please send meteors through their
[ __ ] house
right on their [ __ ] head and their
temple like the middle of the meteor
hits their [ __ ] temple all right
their family their friends their [ __ ]
dog
nuclear level please the love of god
i love you and the holy spirit amen
yeah temple i mean i oh no no no the
temple on the oh okay
yeah
please blow up every
temple that's where my mind was going
i'm sorry
i mean he's obviously talking about me
and he literally said kill their family
our only family in our house is our
[ __ ] two-year-old son he's praying
for his death he's trying to um
mask it with like maybe he's just
kidding
and therefore it's funny and okay but
it's like you're just so i never prayed
for anyone's death yeah the ironic thing
is right after that video cut he
actually driving in that car at like 60
miles an hour hit three dogs on the
freeway
well it's funny because he said okay you
can spare the dog because he that's what
makes it really ironic also this
wouldn't be the first time that he ran
over a dog saying he has a history of
killing prepping for christmas on
christmas right few weeks away on
christmas animals
i wonder if he'll do a uh
i wonder if they'll do the annual
running over the dog this yeah
oh my
god on the 12th day of christmas
the kimster hit my dog
on the 12th day of christmas keemstar
running through my street
12 dead dogs 10 dead children 20.
meters hitting my neighbor's house and
two 20 year olds and two
20 year olds for me
one bold man
one just for men beard died
ten more bandanas
go to
uh two swimming pools to go in with a
full jersey and hat
i just hit a dog going 70 miles per hour
on my truck
still one of my favorite
tweets
that was from 2016. wow it's been a
while yeah
[ __ ] that dude hit killed a dog
murderer
did he ever follow up on the dog
like he hit it at 70. that thing
exploded so it's it's gone
that dog is definitely oh that's so sad
oh my god
exploded that [ __ ]
why would you tweet that wait did he
ever tell the story like did he talk to
the owners of the dog
i don't think there's anything beyond
that tweet oh my god this is cute it's
just that's a keem classic i actually
don't know certified
someone in
he lives in front
what is it yeah he probably like ryan
kavanagh after you know hitting a car
drive off
that's not good that's villain behavior
maybe that's what they have in common
they're both wet and
reckless as according that's what the
police said is that ryan
was under the influence hit a car and
drove off
i wasn't there how the [ __ ] would i know
the super chat
kim is the absolute king of self reports
it really is that's very true
wait there was one thing i wanted to
read
baby do you know where this is
i'm assuming this is the guy you're
referencing from time yeah that's jeff
love yeah
that guy oh my god
[Laughter]
oh my god
keemstar is long lost
maybe
i love in the documentary they're like
oh we got a coat 69 on the property and
they're like oh what does code69 mean oh
there's a hockey thing i love that jeff
lowe thought he was the coolest [ __ ]
thing in the world and then when the
documentary came out he came out like he
discovered he's a [ __ ] loser he's the
worst he's so proud of his lines
yeah that guy is just such a creep man
it's just amazing
reminds me of uh someone else
what is that line about the the um
miscarriage i thought that was in here
oh did they include it in the lawsuit
did you put that in here
oh
yeah so this was like just disgusting
freak [ __ ] they included this in
september 2020 klein entered into a
joint venture to host a show called
frenemies with fellow youtuber trisha
paytas who was engaged to klein's
brother-in-law moses
he took that five
percent exactly imagine if it said that
moses with whom klein has had disputes
with in the past it's like okay bro
disputes in the past though but it's
like everybody gotta everyone i've ever
had a dispute with gotta make a cameo in
this
well what are they even referencing
about this
in the past i don't know nothing well
here wrong
frenemies was extremely pop well they
also said well here you're gonna like
this frenemies was extremely popular
during its nine-month run however after
a series of disputes paid us quit the
show
in june 2021. subsequently client
relentlessly criticized pedes
huh what happened between those two
things
there's a little gap there um klein
criticized peters
illegal
he well so the best part is coming
client relentlessly criticized paid us
and claimed she would be to blame
if klein's pregnant wife suffered a
miscarriage wrong
exactly besides being actually just
[ __ ] wrong like why the [ __ ] would
you need to include that it's just sick
it's
bizarre like i literally didn't say that
to her it was my mom texted it to moses
yeah moses showed it to trisha
i mean they clearly watched a ton of
content to get to this point and then
they on purpose
misrepresented it
isn't this defamation
you can't defame someone in a court
proceeding
as far as i understand
but
why would they include this it's like
just weird and freaking disgusting
very weird and
lying patis has reported uh receiving
relentless harassment via text and
online leading to a withdrawal from the
online communities from which she
derives all of her income that's wrong
you gotta love that right i mean she's
still making she's still making content
and money
and this is just bizarre
well
[Laughter]
yeah it's weird it's like
i think no
it says trip patis reported receiving i
think they're just talking about her
videos
i'm assuming
i gotta
thank you
john bless thank you thank you thank you
thank you
who was that
papa papa john
why do you say it like that say it again
does he say it like that it was his papa
bless papa flex things
anyway that's about it eh
that's about it
for that's all i have to say about that
i may not be a smart man but i do know
something's [ __ ] up when i see it
everything's gonna see all right
so let's move on to ace family because
there's some really good updates here
we made a whole four hour
video speculating and wondering about
what was this loan they got you know
yeah that big shredder is like just
straight up sleeping
so cute
[Music]
so cute
[Music]
[Music]
so cute
how is it real
dogs
i know dogs are just
so too good
so
um what did we find here the deaf
noodles obviously found some really
contractor
did we find the original here
so i should watch this video right uh ab
yeah it's 11 minutes long though so well
i don't care we got time let's do it
yeah so this person found some really
good challenges
who was on site who created their
relationship with austin who got austin
to basically be interested in the house
right the guy who was there every day
he was not a licensed contractor and he
was using someone else's contracting
license and we were unaware of it for
two years okay so he lied to us and said
that he's the contractor but in reality
the real contractors was this
contracting company called tnl
constructions so they're the real
contractors to this house and the only
licensed contractors through this house
so our builder just told us something
and we're going to have him restate for
the video
is this video all just receipts and
video clips yo
shout out
this is so funny so go ahead so anyway
the contractor they are referring to and
oh my god they even got the robot voice
you know the contractor probably made it
their video is someone by the name of
avi cochliny
avi is the builder austin originally
approached to combine the two properties
into a mega mansion
[Music]
and why is he important to this puzzle
this is awesome
as seen in this official statement of
information filed with the secretary of
state of california avi kochlani is one
of the owners of m development llc along
with his brother tammy cockley both
individuals are named as beneficial
owners of the company furthermore note
that the type of business is labeled as
construction development and remodeling
and development is important because
they had been the previous owners of the
ace family property from 2016 until
austin and catherine moved in as seen in
this permanent application who the [ __ ]
made this this is amazing got all the
documents and everything yeah
and from two small towns and development
is listed okay so this is the concrete
boss
as we lovingly describe right yes
owner of the property during the
development and construction of the ace
family compound the property only ever
had something called an owner builder
permit an owner builder is what the term
indicates the person owns the property
and acts as the general contractor on
the job and either does the work or has
employees or licensed subcontractors
work on the project in this case the
owner builder is avi and he was never
legally required to have a contractor's
license and the ace family always knew
this catherine was interesting right so
her whole thing about
he never had a license
he didn't even need to have one not
relevant not irrelevant he's an owner
owner and they would have known her
wow whoa right out the gate this is good
[ __ ] yeah
shout out to floor
600 subscribers yeah i don't know what
this channel is what other videos do
they have on this
what other [ __ ] these guys making
again
oh my god it's like all
ace family [ __ ]
austin mcbroom caught scamming
his family caught lying
what who was making this channel man
holy [ __ ] damned they hate the ace
family
direct and saying that tnl was
technically the only licensed thing it's
probably obvi he's like [ __ ] dude
interesting i got all the receipts
contractors but under the owner builder
permit for the property it was
completely legal for tnl to work as
subcontractors under their unlicensed
general contract deravi this would have
been all over the paperwork they signed
okay so catherine and austin took out an
over official statement of information
because the development is what the term
in this case be the only
this would have been all over the
paperwork they signed
yeah that's super interesting so
they say he was lied to us he's not a
real contractor that's irrelevant what's
sketchy about this is that in april 2019
catherine and austin became officers of
m development llc with an ownership
interest that is odd
so m development llc is the company avi
owns
that he's building the house from right
and then they became officers
on april 11
2019 and development llc's statement of
information was legally changed to
include ace hat collection incorporated
austin and catherine as officers of the
company the business address of the
company was even changed to austin and
catherine's home address also note that
the type of business for m development
llc changed from construction
development and remodeling to
entertainment catherine's signature is
at the bottom of this paperwork
[Music]
this is so weird
[Music]
it gets better
how can an entertainment company build a
house
in the context of it being a set
essentially which well they started the
project as construction right and then
they changed it to entertainment that is
odd that is some [ __ ] for sure
while partial owners of m development
llc austin and catherine obtained an
ownership interest as borrowers along
with tammy cochleney while borrowers of
m development catherine and austin took
out an over 3.5 million dollar loan from
five arch funding
so why would catherine austin become
partial owners of m development llc
that's the big question isn't it
in my opinion they became members of m
development llc because under an owner
builder permit the property is
ineligible for resale unless the owner
builder has lived at the property for at
least 12 months one loophole to this
situation is a quick claim deed a quick
claim deed is an instrument used to
transfer real property such as real
estate the exception is that they can be
used when a property transfers ownership
without technically being sold that is
when no money is involved that's their
house it's [ __ ] huge what the hell
how big is that house two houses
together i know but like [ __ ]
i didn't realize it was so bad they can
be used when a property transfers
ownership without technically being big
jesus
it's like a mega mansion yep
is when no money is involved therefore
no resale occurred and the mcbrooms can
officially become owners they likely
exchanged money for the property outside
of the quit claim deed since quit claim
d transfers are considered gifts they
are typically used between family
members or business partners
transferring property interest while
still partial owners of m development
austin and catherine entered into a quit
claim deed with the cochlear family they
transferred the deed solely to ace hat
collection and subsequently austin and
catherine removed themselves as owners i
believe the mcbroom family became
temporary owners to make the quitclaim
transfer more legitimate and possibly
for tax reasons too it also makes me
believe they were always aware that
their general contractor never had a
license since they were aware of the
owner builder permit and they went
through all that trouble to disguise the
sale of the property
they were in deep with this guy
that is so weird so
just to recap as i'm understanding what
this person is trying to say
you do this house you build it for
yourself
you have to live in it for a year before
you can sell it because the type of loan
so technically avi avi's the one that
owned it
and his company
so to get around the law
of avi having to live in it for a year
they
pretended to join his company
and didn't use this quick claim thing
paid him out like under the table or
whatever probably
what the [ __ ] bro
this is so shady it sounds illegal like
mortgage fraud like
mortgage fraud i feel like they could
actually go to jail for that if it
really pans out like what's the crime
for mortgage crime is it jail or just
massive fines
[Music]
yo these guys are such pieces of [ __ ]
and then to come out here and like [ __ ]
on this guy
okay let's continue on this is real
interesting i got a certificate of
occupancy we are not legally be able to
be occupants in our home that we've been
paying for that we purchased for almost
three years we have never had a
certificate of occupation while it is
true that they never had a certificate
of occupancy that isn't the only reason
why they were never legally allowed to
live at the property in july 2019 austin
and catherine took out an almost nine
million dollar mortgage loan with five
arch funding as the lender in the loans
agreement the conditions were that the
loan was for business purposes and under
no circumstance shall the borrower
occupy establish or use the
property any part thereof as borrowers
residents or residents of any principle
that's
that's a smoking gun right there it
would seem
that would explain why they got a loan
to begin with in a place that's not
livable right because we were wondering
like
how did they even get alone then
what the [ __ ]
i gotta i gotta hear that again that is
just that's like actual
not only are they
scum they're also dumb because they put
this all online and they're challenging
people to uncover their fraud which is
out in daylight
yeah their fans obviously don't care so
like i don't understand the motivation
to make that video like this is going to
backfire on them so hard
austin and catherine took out an almost
nine million dollar mortgage loan with
five art so what kind of loan was this
it was like they're apparently
i'm reading some of the writing here
not sure that it says here
in the loans agreement the conditions
were that the loan was for business
purposes and under no circumstance shall
the borrower occupy establish or use the
property or any part thereof as
borrowers residents or residents of any
troops they got a flip loan they got a
loan to build a house and sell it not to
live in it how did this person get the
loan documents
i think it's public i think it's public
i think they just just did the legwork
i think i think it's public so it's like
they give you this massive loan on a
short term because you're supposed to
build the house sell the house oh
shredder needs to
go outside
hang on shreddy don't jump to your death
thank you thank you
sure
maybe yeah yeah he needs to go out
so they give you this massive loan with
the short term because you're supposed
to build the house and then sell the
house and pay back the money
you're not it's not a 30-year
loan it's like it was like a 16-month
loan
yo
why you [ __ ] lying you don't think
there's a chance this guy got it wrong
right
i mean i guess there's a chance some
random anonymous account but they said
well the ace family said it was a 60
month loan and they're like
right i know it i mean it fits yeah it
does fit it fits idiot
the agreement went on to say the
property is owned by the borrower
exclusively for commercial purpose
either for repair or resale this means
that they obtain the mortgage under
false pretenses making the lenders
believe that they were not living there
and only using the property to work in
film or to flip and resell at a later
date austin mcbroom signed the agreement
and by making this their permanent
residence catherine and austin committed
mortgage fraud they were never legally
allowed to occupy the residence because
of this i don't know they told people
that whoever was like writing the
underwriter permits permanent to build
they told them that they weren't
actually going to live there they were
going to film there and they would city
that yeah and they moved in anyways
primarily right so anyways so we've
never had gas so just so you guys know
our winters are getting really cold in
l.a we live in a glass house we were
freezing in our house we were so
freaking cold there was no heat no
nothing because we didn't have hot water
and i was giving my babies a full bath
because i didn't have a choice if you
were so concerned for your poor babies
and bathing them in cold water while
having them live in dangerous conditions
then why didn't you sell the place when
you were offered double the price watch
the next clip when you were upper double
the price guess what someone just
offered to buy our house for double the
price we bought for you're mine i'm dead
ass i wouldn't lie about that you know i
wouldn't live on that okay so what for
double the price of bodybuilding no no
no no
this is actually so good because
this person dug up all the goods yeah
because in the video we watched
of their explanation they're like i knew
in my heart that just we needed to get
out of there that's why i never bought
furniture for the house right yeah
and then someone comes and offers them
double and they say no i mean sorry
blood boiling
yes it was just something like
absolutely ridiculous
we were literally like scammed and it's
so crazy because people use that word so
lightly when it comes to us like the ace
family
was the bank by you guys in reality you
guys got scammed
that's crazy man
and it's like no we've never scammed
anyone we've been scammed multiple times
over and over and over and over in
reality
i like
you guys
and like the neighbors were complaining
and this and that and we didn't really
speak on it because like well now i can
finally speak on it so i'm gonna speak
on it right now there should be nothing
wrong ever ever ever with an owner of a
home doing anything he wants with his
pool you got a pool you freaking happy
to tell you if you want to put a frickin
jet ski
in yeah i love i was i heard her say i
was like what are you a libertarian now
i don't know about jet ski in the pool i
feel like
i'm okay with having a law about that
yeah
we had lots of jokes about that when we
watched it
except you signed an agreement with your
lender stating that you would preserve
the property and not do anything
well
to
damage
go receipts
receipts
borrowers shall not destroy damage or
impair the property allow the property
to deteriorate or commit waste on the
property
borrower shall maintain the property as
good and safe condition and repair in
order to prevent the property from
deteriorating or decreasing in value
causing landslides do you think that's a
this video is awesome dude
there's it is
this person must be a fan right because
they got
dude what are you doing
they were talking about how they thought
the pool was so unsafe in the video and
they were scared to go on it i was like
you're trying to but if you think that
pool's unsafe and you're going around
like that
but this is the issue there was no
retaining wall built around the bottom
hill of our house because the the
builder didn't build one he didn't get a
certificate so our builder actually took
it upon himself and built a whole entire
retaining wall down below
yeah in the video she was saying how the
builder [ __ ] them and
the reason why their pool leaks is
because he didn't build a retaining wall
uh it's just crazy how they lie didn't
build one he didn't get a certificate so
our builder actually took it upon
himself and built a whole entire
retaining wall down below
the third time uh we got a complaint and
even though there was a retaining wall
which i understand like it's still the
matter of the fact but it's still my
property on the water is going
sorry but take responsibility
oh it's right here i'm sorry but take
responsibility for one thing this
builder seems guilty of a lot but to
blame him for your just for you
disturbing your neighbors
with noise and a monsoon of chlorinated
water is absurd
true that's what it was
also had cracks in it
in the video in this exact video she
said
that eventually she just they couldn't
get alone and she just was like praying
for
the best
basically praying for someone in city
hall to save eighth family
you also own two office suites at a
commercial building and you are
delinquent on property taxes for both
that means you don't pay your bills my
life
oh my god this person is out of control
how does this person know all this stuff
they probably just looked up their
business ace hat family or whatever the
[ __ ]
delinquents
well keemstar also had a lean on his
house we learned that was awesome yeah
that was like it turned into a story
right
yeah
should we talk about that
uh i
i'd have to brush up on the details it
was like a quarter quarter million
dollar tax lien for unpaid taxes
wow
dude you live in buffalo come on bro did
your house cost like 10 bucks
sorry that was mean classes or something
[Music]
18 months i pay like it goes and then it
comes back and i'm like what the hell
when somebody just come back into my
account right because i get all the
accounting and look at everything i'm
like uh what's going on with the lenders
like my money just came back he goes oh
like they're saying that they don't want
to do do it anymore like they don't want
to like yeah wonder why
yeah they don't want to be the lenders
anymore like basically you guys are out
of your [ __ ] mind to come out here
and pretend to be the victim
again just such an unforced error too
like why make this video
their fans support them unconditionally
like i think it's the ego they can't
take the
the fact that this is now what they're
known for that they got foreclosure on
their house right well when i was
watching that the one thing that kept
they kept they were so wanted people to
think they were rich they didn't want
anyone to think that they were poor
but the thing is like yeah i mean they
bought a lot of sympathy with their fans
oh see they even vlogged it last day of
the ace family house bye forever that's
so crazy because a month ago they were
like
[ __ ] haters
yeah he said something along the lines
that we only got two lawsuits and it's
this and that's not us we're fine just
people hating
why the [ __ ] you lying
um
a lot of people in the chat pointing out
that you just enjoyed a buffalo a
chicken calzone
so this buffalo slander will not stand
okay all right
because i have to love everything with
buffalo
i mean that calzone kind of slapped it
was good
can i say it so i love buffalo [ __ ]
you know what i'm just going to freaking
keep living my life keep doing what i do
just be positive to stay positive and
stay positive and then one day i'm on
like instagram or something and someone
goes why is your house under closure
this is what she's saying she was told
they can't get a loan
and then she's like i'm just gonna stay
positive
you don't stay positive during a loan
yeah you owe the money it doesn't matter
you have to pay the the
you have to pay the more would her say
that i was like what the [ __ ] let me go
back
and go find somebody so they're like
whatever you know what i'm just going to
freaking keep it like my money
like they're saying that they don't want
to do it anymore like they don't want to
like keep they want they don't they
don't want to be letters yeah they don't
want to be the lenders anymore like
basically like go freaking go find
somebody else so then i'm like whatever
you know what i'm just going to freaking
keep living my life keep doing what i do
just be positive yeah and not paying my
bills
if you're not paying the bill that
doesn't mean it just disappeared that's
very true i'm just going to keep living
my life keep staying positive he's
family you gotta pay them though you
know that right
she's like and then magically we got
four clothes done
i'm trying to get some attention
i have to stay positive captain stay
positive and then one day i'm on like
instagram or something someone goes why
is your house under for closure and i'm
like what the hell am i i was staying
positive for three months what the hell
and one day somebody said i'm being
forgotten
you had it okay so this this gets into
it you hadn't made a mortgage payment in
six months wow received a notice of
default but you were shocked when and
into foreclosure
holy [ __ ]
[Music]
a little big lebowski once the original
thunder said screw you guys were out of
here so i handled a slew of foreclosures
so i know how the process works and
captain mcgroom's out there and expects
us to believe that well she said i sent
the payment and i looked in my account
and the money came back and i didn't
know what happened alan what's going on
he's like oh the bank doesn't want to
deal with you anymore so they're not
going gonna take your money well first
of all that's [ __ ] they can't refuse
to take your money there would have to
be some other condition present for them
not to take it either you've already
defaulted and they've decided we're not
gonna take your money now because it's
too late we're gonna proceed with the
foreclosure or your loan came due and
you didn't pay what you were supposed to
pay at the end of the loan and so
they're not going to take your money but
they don't just decide randomly you have
an agreement with them you know when you
take a mortgage on a property there's
this huge stack of paperwork that you do
they can't just randomly say oh we've
decided we don't want to do business
with you anymore your original lender
said we're out of here because they
found out that you committed mortgage
fraud and were violating the terms of
your legal agreement whether you
defaulted or committed fraud they had
every legal right to terminate the
agreement and start the foreclosure
process the lenders who let us that the
loan for our mortgage they said screw
you we don't care about your 70k a month
right we're gonna buy this bus for 10
million
yes that's what happens when you're in
foreclosure when you default and violate
your agreement the property goes back to
the lender so they can get their money
back
oh you are so dumb you are really dumb
for real we just got an appraisal just a
couple months ago when all this [ __ ] was
going out our house is worth 16.5
million
right that's what the appraisal like
praise it
then why didn't you sell it for the
appraisal value made back the nine
million loan and still have six million
left in profit
like what's going on builder who is like
the main piece of this whole situation
um we're doing our research and come to
find out he was basically going bankrupt
he didn't have [ __ ] to his name so a lot
of times you can't sue anybody if they
don't have anything uh just appointments
and we be we were asked out and we were
able to you know obviously sue him
because he doesn't have anything it
would just be a waste of time and energy
and money
the truth is
a lot of people talk about how the
energy between them is so weird how he
keeps looking at her like
don't say the wrong thing or you keep
trying to stop her before she says
something yeah it's so awkward well
they're both drunk in the video for sure
especially i don't think she is but
especially him
the truth is that they cannot sue the
builder because the property was
constructed under an owner builder
permit legally the responsibility falls
towards them because california law only
protects customers from construction
work that isn't taken out in their name
well there you [ __ ] go bingo bingo
we only have two lot we have lessons
against this right
not sure
that it's more than that babe
well i have three so who am i who am i
to uh laugh true
but at least you know the amount oh i
can tell you very definitely is three
how many lawsuits this is
um
like and subscribe wow what a video wow
what a [ __ ] journey give the channel
a shout out again yeah that was uh
[ __ ] well it's what is the channel floor
floor f-l-e-u-r
and they're all they do is make ace
family videos
let's see
it's a brand new channel
two weeks ago ace family lying for 11
minutes straight
awesome groom cheating on kaplan
compilation
catherine mcbroom 1212 gateway
ace family caught selling furniture
um
why the [ __ ] you lying
why you always
i'm not shouting them out okay so like a
pedo or something oh yeah right i'm just
saying here's the channel
i'm not allowed to do shout outs anymore
shout out to his family
oh this should i read this comment um
someone said uh austin got a quick claim
d because they were trying to avoid
taxes
i don't understand the ins and outs of
that and no wonder they weren't able to
sell the house since a quick claim deed
offers no security for the buyer like a
regular warranty deed if there's any
liens mortgages or other encumbrances on
the property
it could all fall to the buyer it's
already no guarantee that the seller
actually even has any rights to sell the
property so of course nobody is going to
want that mess of a house
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] show that situation
is can't y'all just buy a house like
just buy a house
why you got to do everything so weird
oh this is our last one steve will do it
another keemstar related drama you gotta
love that
wait this is cav cav what the [ __ ] is
this
oh dramaalert posted this no way
so dramaalert has an instagram account
dude
right now so [ __ ] bffs
keepstar kavanaugh are literally bffs
dan have you seen this keemstar posted
kavanaugh
on instagram
the end of h3h3
yeah right from one day ago
go back to retirement yeah [ __ ] the
end of h3
h3 needs to stop harassing harming and
attempting to destroy other people's
lives by spreading and false and
malicious lies
unfortunately it looks like i'm going to
have to be the one to stop him
i believe within months his channel will
be banned from youtube
i'll share this yeah he shared this nice
picture by the way
you want to know how i think of ryan
cavanaugh
here i'll show you how i think of ryan
cavanaugh when i think of him
how do you think of him when i imagine
ryan cavanaugh
this is what i imagine
this is what he should have posted
you you put up in a
this image
that's right kavanagh amazing invitation
on your instagram is he here this is my
man right here what is going on there
like is it is that like a
just a long sleeve white shirt with a
white t-shirt over it nothing makes
sense because
that's really strange like what is that
it looks like a weird venomous like
parody piece
but yeah i don't know but yeah that's my
boy right there
dana should
take his money and
have his bike
in his backyard
won't come answering my text messages so
i don't know if
he wants a lion dog face pony soldier
dana sucks
also drunk so this was so dramaalert
also
quote tweeted um
steve will do it
one day ago
h3h3s a loser
that's breaking news
on the dramaalert instagram page
that's awesome right
huge facts h3 is a turtle that's from
the write it out [ __ ] yeah
so that first post that had cap cav in
it that's where steve will do it
commented
oh [ __ ] i gotta go back
there's a whole there's a whole
connection does he just post about me
every day on instagram what is this [ __ ]
zack this is i don't know i'm correct
right about that right zach that's where
he's yeah yeah the ryan cavanaugh post
was right where steve commented and then
they posted that and then that was a
breaking story
why okay all right what is happening
i keep trying to open okay thank you did
someone okay they flipped it for you
it's the same one what the [ __ ] is
happening ab you gave me the same link
i'm clicking this [ __ ]
okay here it is again
what's happening here i have four of
them you got you got a new link maybe
you want me to click
here it is once again
you gotta where the [ __ ] am i supposed
to click dude it's in
okay which link
it's the
go ahead
it's the it's the
it's right here i'm highlighting it
[Music]
bro if this is steve will do it i'm
gonna lose my [ __ ] mind here i got it
i got it
here open this link
oh damn it it didn't work because i just
put it in there
okay here's the link zach sent me
[ __ ] stephen
i didn't send you that wait what
i told you the right one huh
okay here's one that loves me
you just clicked it wait
[Laughter]
click the [ __ ] highlighted link here
it's highlighted all right here
it's [ __ ] steve well you're [ __ ]
with it
i literally just clicked it
wait send me the link you just opened
olivia
send me on discord the one that works
tell me when you've sent it
i have gone to my phone
i am sending now from my phone all right
let me click the link abcent
[Music]
what the [ __ ] amy
are you guys [ __ ] with me i just sent
it i literally just said it in the
discord all right let me click the link
if i was new i'd have a [ __ ] panic
attack
yo what the [ __ ]
get the [ __ ] out of here dude
okay [ __ ] is flipped
okay i found the right one i found the
right there we go
poor love's been spamming it 60 times
it's like these stupid americans
uh i found it
all right so here is this and then in
the comments is steve will do it guy's a
loser
i mean bro i mean
you want to talk about loser
you literally scammed your fans and now
you're broke
also your thumbnail has you with trump
that's peak then
i believe he lost the election so
technically he is a loser
i'm gonna
[Laughter]
i guess i am a loser i don't [ __ ]
shotgun beers on a nightly basis and
[ __ ] hot chicks every night well can you
what's on astro world
it on after a while
what do you think he means by me being a
loser
that i can't beerbonk three beers at
once
that you
don't
[Music]
yeah i'm
playing video games i think he called
coffeezilla loser too anyone who could
you know
he was a loser i feel like you know if
he was a true knock boy he would have
called you a half center so i feel like
this is fake no boy behavior he's like
that dude doesn't even have a fatty
liver yeah this is from excessive
drinking it's just fake [ __ ] milk
boyism
you are full sender ethan he's like that
bro doesn't even have pre-liver disease
it's half center
is it rona season
okay so he said what a loser and that
game's just like broken [ __ ] dude
people do it
hey she's a loser
via dramaalert comment
i'm surprised you didn't re-approach
bradley martin
oh he probably didn't see it yet he
probably will he'll just keep this chain
going yeah
awesome
some hard hitting reporting right there
what the [ __ ] why is the best that's why
he's at his
retiring at his peak
going out
with style that's right i do gotta it's
not as good as csq though i mean come on
all right now i gotta close all these
[ __ ] windows i'll see if we'll do it
you guys
[Music]
what the [ __ ] look at all these
this is outrageous
this is so inappropriate like no no
shoddys or anything are you gonna rip a
dart
no shot is or anything
i'm done
i'm just oh here it is
40 000 likes guys
who agrees
who agrees
can i get a shout out
everyone well
it didn't go that well because look the
second reply no he's better than steve
so
h3 is so old i guess that does make me a
loser loser did i miss the sound
[Laughter]
who agrees
that's news guys
me they this guy agrees [ __ ] yeah
wow a 55 year old dating a 20 year old
trying to get people online to bully the
person he hates like a 12 year old h3 is
everything keemstar loss and it makes
them crazy now there's a [ __ ] comment
that's a comment god you don't even have
to scroll for these yeah it's like it's
the top comment amazing oh who's h3h3
okay that's good that's a little shadow
i mean he's getting my name out there
that's fine can everyone can someone
explain why everyone's mad at h3 i
didn't do anything i think you're just
on the wrong page i'm just spitting
facts you know
so he thinks making all those cringe
videos for clout doesn't make him a
loser but h3h3r lol dude has so many
ball suckers around
what
well
okay someone said he's right though i
guess
i'm right
or he daniel's right
yeah
i mean grammatically though didn't
really need to be there
i think they're saying he's right though
well dan this person's probably nine
years old give him a break i've never
heard you call him by his real name i
don't think this person said i thought
that was odd yeah right he called him
daniel that was so weird yeah yeah yeah
don't you think it's better to call him
daniel it's like okay daniel
keemstar it's like he's daniel slander
hold on
there's nothing wrong with daniel i'm
just saying
oh your girlfriend's here
she is she brought us gifts i was like
what am i looking at right now
we love ellie ally please stand up hi
ellie
she's totally not even looking over here
no it's not it's not against his name
it's against like he's like i'm keemstar
it's like no you're daniel yeah damn
he's just a guy yeah daniel dan's a cool
name daniel's like little boy you know
like a little
[ __ ] what you're saying
thanks for playing it's like a little
boy that wasn't playing that
little [ __ ]
gotta love that news network so good
that's the best best of the best my
friends
maybe we'll see um it in kavanaugh's ads
soon
as sure is a loser by steve we'll do it
we should promote that promoted
it seems like it'll be pretty funny yeah
i'm up for that
all right i guess we're out of time
we've probably been going for a while
right family family family family family
family family family family
family oh it sounds like the jet ski guy
yeah
or maybe you should hit the stop zone
zack
so you do it don't leave it up there
yeah you're giving him too much power
yeah i'm gonna let that go
forever
okay let's just try it with the button
and then you guys can set me up with the
button um
[ __ ] you daniel how about that
chill chill chill
all right well i finally get to go play
final fantasy
hell yeah okay
okay loser you're [ __ ] loser i
knew what are you going to do
okay
i'm deflating your baby no
oh [ __ ]
that'll work
i didn't know that's what that did yeah
talk [ __ ] again i dare
you okay loser
uh
i'm going to read off some donations
because there's been a lot and we
haven't really done any today so let me
just wrap it fire uh random but ethan
try out elder scrolls online for a new
game he just he's got final fantasy 14.
yeah
i played uh eso a little bit my
girlfriend loves it she plays it all the
time so shout out i always wanted to
because i love you know the elder
scrolls that played them all
but i
heard it was bad so i never picked it up
it's it's not bad it's good but i'm in
final fantasy he's in he's in the world
of ivelisse
uh
two dollars my first ever super chat big
love olivia shout out to olivia
oh my god
that's right thank you um somebody
donated uh 50
dkk r is that korean cash danish
chronicles oh danish
uh
and gave like a little gif that says
keep it up
i didn't know you could do that so very
nice oh [ __ ] wait keemstar just posted
this
this is breaking news
h3 is a turd
bradley martin via dramaalert comments
huge breaking news who agrees news who
agrees who agrees yeah likes
type type get and tell in the comments
if you agree told us the beginning show
you dropped a huge turd so last night uh
i feel like it's my civic duty to share
the ryan kavanaugh's own relativity
media worked on fast and furious four
since we're on the family train love you
family for life that's right and i think
i think some of the other ones
family family family family family
family family family stop i'm trying to
find some big ones because oh wait love
you were writing them in the chat yeah
okay let me just read those off because
i want to tell them
okay 100
uh stephanie mcdonald uh here's a
hundred dollars to fund along with my
monthly membership i am so sick of men
like kavkav and keemstar such fragile
male egos youtube would not let me
submit the chat until i removed a swear
word
thank you
[Applause]
a much better place
uh thank you so much uh thank you
garrett donate 100 and said the doctor
told me this is 200.
wait say that again
it's a little burn on zach it's a good
one garrett yeah
yes yes very nice very nice thank you
thank
uh
or
and forge donate 50 british pound
sterling and said as a law student i
hope you succeed with this lawsuit
because frankly you're about to set
another common law judge made law
precedent on fair use because expressing
your views is important to keep people
like kavanaugh to account hi from the uk
thank you so much
thank you so much are you worried that
we're about to fall off
just like move forward
uh h3 crew this is my first time
donating become a member to the channel
i love you all thank you for this
blessed entertainment papa bless you
love bot i love you dog by the way ethan
rocking that bucket hat like a god
thank you guys wow i was gonna say i'm
not looking to do any precedent i don't
want to do any president i don't want to
be sued i don't want to deal with this
[ __ ] at all but these [ __ ]
they're making it happen
but thank you for your support you know
family yeah thank you very much for
family
i have a confession i was a paid actor
by a b to b rk to plan his eventual
overtake of h3 in the whole hollywood
family family family family i'm starting
to get family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family family
it doesn't sound like a word anymore
yeah sounds like emily
uh yada yada
i'm sorry there's i'm sure there's some
other good ones in here what oh oh we
have a transformation we got to say it
first don't show me well you're kind of
late if you've been a little faster
uh
thirty dollars name is x i listen to
your podcast while i'm chilling anyways
i've been in a pretty good mood this
week so here's thirty dollars hey
thanks man
i mean that
name name is x that's how the yes x out
here name is x i listen to your podcast
while i'm chilling
i've been a pretty good mood this week
so here's 30. i'm a pretty cool dude my
friends call me x
well thanks that's you are cool dude you
are a very cool dude if dan wants to
goof on you i got nothing that was just
the way that was just the way i got a
phrase and respect and love for mr x all
right
doctor x
let's see uh fifty dollars day two of
asking how much it would cost to have
ethan officiate my wedding completely in
the godfather voice just got engaged
last week how much would how much would
you like
how much money you got okay that's a
good response
all right come to me on the day of your
wedding
asking for a favor
you want to pay me
no no no
i you can pay me in favor someday i may
come to you
and i will ask you for a favor
that day may never come
[Music]
but when that day comes
what
family family family
family family family family family
family family family family family
family
you're fired love love get out
shut them up shut him down
uh cat kitty donated 500 yen and said i
wouldn't have even heard of triller it
doesn't exist in japan if it wasn't for
his pettiness keep fighting the good
fight ethan love you all and then some
japanese kanji which i cannot read oh i
think they translate afterwards it's
family they wrote family and japanese
love
love out in japan yep that's cool
uh
all right let's go home it's the weekend
baby how long did we go for uh like
three and a half hours or so three and a
half yeah we're doing marathons this
week yeah
crazy let me double check that maybe
just three it's almost four thirty ten
minutes we really do three and three
hours and ten minutes three hours ten
minutes there you go all right well guys
thank you for watching i hope you have a
fantastic weekend remembers that a new
leftovers will be out on sunday it's
going to be a great episode
i forgot to do this on wednesday so let
me do it now there is a survey in the
description
if you have a couple minutes uh just
click the link and fill it out it'll
help us out with uh our sponsors and all
that kind of stuff only if you got the
time though not a big deal not a big
deal if you're super [ __ ] bored if
you were born you have nothing better to
do nothing happening in your life
fill out this survey with peace and love
with peace and love yeah so if you're a
member you'll get to watch leftovers on
saturday yes indeed and if not uh it
will be available for everyone on sunday
we love you no matter what your status
is
that's right that's right you're
watching that's right we love it that's
right
they said we wouldn't come back but we
always do embrace from the ashes like
the phoenix on the flex back to two
[Music]
you're watching h23